THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE-
STREET BUILDING IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISK THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BURKE
DISSIPATION. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN A
NUMBER OF TIMES TODAY. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND ALSO FOR
OUR COURT REPORTER I'M GONNA ASK
ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES A LIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY SOMETIMES WE HAVE A
FEW TECHNICAL PROBLEMS ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE AND I HAVE TO
INTERRUPT AND ASK PEOPLE TO SLOW
DOWN A RESTATE THINGS. PLEASE
FORGIVE ME FOR THAT HAVE SOME
PATIENTS WE JUST WANT TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE WE GET YOUR-
TESTIMONY. IT'S IMPORTANT. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
AND IT IS A BUSY FULL AGENDA
JUST TO POINT OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUES. WE WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND TO MY COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME THAT WE VOTE. SO
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY WITH
OUR MICROPHONES BUT THERE WE GO. THE GROVE KAMLAGER HERE
KAMLAGER HERE LAYERED HERE
LAYERED HERE BATES HERE BATES
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE
THANK YOU. SO IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS I WOULD TAKE UP FIRST
ON TODAY'S AGENDA- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT WOULD BE ITEMS
TO G. AND H. THESE ARE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE WESTERN
STATES WATER COUNCIL. I WOULD
MOVE THOSE APPOINTMENTS CENTER
GLARED THANK YOU FOR THAT MOTION
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LAYERED
AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE A MOTION FOR ITEM
THREE THE BILL REFERRAL AND ITEM
FOR FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS BY
SENATORS. SENATOR COM LAGER.
MADE A MOTION MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GROWTH
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER AYE LAYERED
AYE LAYERED AYE BATES AYE BATES
AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS FIVE FORTY
ZERO FORTY ZERO THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW TURN TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ITEMS
ONE A THROUGH D. THESE ARE
APPOINTMENTS OF MEMBERS TO THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. AND OUR-
OF APPOINTEES AND- COMMISSIONERS
TODAY ARE- MISTER ALAN BARCELONA
MISTER RICHARD BRAZIL- MISTER
KELLY GORDON AND MISS TINA NIETO
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THESE ALL
ARE- IN ADDITION TO BEING
COMMISSIONERS SOME ARE.
CERTAINLY HAVE OTHER TITLES BUT
I DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT TO ME
I'LL GET IT AS I CALL ON YOU
INDIVIDUALLY- BUT I CAN SAY
COMMISSIONER I KNOW SOME OF YOU
HAVE TITLES IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THAT THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
TITLES I DON'T MEAN NOT TO.
MENTION THEM BUT- FOR PURPOSES
OF TODAY I WE WILL CALL YOU
COMMISSIONER- AND WE'RE GONNA
START WITH COMMISSIONER
BARCELONA AND- WHAT I WOULD
INVITE EACH OF YOU TO DO IS TO-
A KNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE THANK YOU WHEN YOU WOULD
LIKE MAKE OPENING COMMENTS. WILL
GO TO EACH OF THE APPOINTEES
COMMISSIONERS ONE AFTER ANOTHER
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO MEMBERS
WILL START WITH COMMISSIONER
BARCELONA AND THEN GO TO
COMMISSIONER BRAZIL BOTH OF
THESE ARE RE APPOINTMENTS AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO
COMMISSIONER GORDON AND
COMMISSIONER NIETO- AS WELL
THESE ARE NEW APPOINTMENTS AND
WITH THAT- COMMISSIONER
BARCELONA WHY DON'T YOU GO
AHEAD- A KNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WANT MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU BOB MONDELLO I'M A
SPECIAL AGENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. YEAH
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ASSOCIATION AND
THE- THIS IS MY SECOND. WOULD BE
MY CELL TERM ON THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU- OKAY I WILL GO TO
COMMISSIONER AND CHIEF BRAZIL A
REAPPOINTMENT COMMISSIONER-
REPRESENT ALL ON A FIRST ONE
NIGHT THAT THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THE STAFF HAS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN THIS.
ASSESS I AM LOOKING FOR TO
RECONFIRM WE'VE BEEN FOR A LOT
OF CHANGE IN THE POST- OVER THE
LAST SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN ON THE
COMMISSION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A HUGE SEA CHANGE IN WHAT WE
DO IS POST A AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE FUTURE-
AND I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
THINK MANY OVER AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STAFF THERE
THEY'VE DONE JUST A PHENOMENAL
JOB WITH THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
CHANGE AND WORK- AND- CULTURE. A
POST SOMEONE WANNA GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO THEM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I WILL MOVE NOW
TO- COMMISSIONER AND CHIEF
GORDEN TO- TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M THANKFUL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SIR I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAFF AT POSTED
MAINTAINED CHESAPEAKE THEY HAVE
A FANTASTIC LEADER OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ALVAREZ. I
WOULD LIKE T READ JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON MYSELF
SINCE I'M A NEW APPOINTEE I HAVE
OVER TWENTY SIX YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE I'VE
WORKED FOR THREE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES IS VERY WITH LAPD
WORKING MAJORITY OF MY CAREER
WITH MONTEBELLO AND THE LAST
FIVE YEARS I HAVE WORKED FOR
MODERATE PART P. AS CHIEF FOR
THE LAST TWO. I HAVE A MASTERS
OF- LEADERSHIP AND FROM ST
MARY'S COLLEGE. I'M A GRADUATE
OF THE FBI NATIONAL ACADEMY POST
EXECUTIVE ELEMENTS JUST TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF MY
EDUCATION. I SERVE A ON SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND CURRENTLY
SERVES AS THE FIRST VICE
PRESIDENT FOR L. A. COUNTY.
POLICE SHE'S ASSOCIATION I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CAL CHEESE.
JANEANE COMMITTEE FOR CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS. AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN DEPLOYED TO SEVERAL LARGE
SCALE INCIDENTS AS A DISASTER-
CAN I DISASTROUS FOR SPECIALS
INCLUDING THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER. COULD TRINA ERNESTO JUST
TO. NAME A COUPLE. I'M VERY VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE SUPPORT OF MY
WIFE AND MY THREE AMAZING
CHILDREN. MY WIFE IS A LICENSED
MARRIAGE FAMILY THERAPIST WHO
WORKS IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
SPECIALIZES IN CHILDREN THAT
IDENTIFY WITH THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY SO SHE PROVIDES ME
WITH A VERY. IMPORTANT
PERSPECTIVE IN THE WORK THAT I
DO. OUR CHILDREN ALSO DO A GREAT
JOB KEEP ME GROUNDED OUR OLDEST
HAS HER MASTER'S DEGREE IN
SOCIAL WORK AND WORK FOR
ADOPTION FOSTER CARE AGENCY. OUR
MIDDLE IS EMBARKING UPON HER
JOURNEY AS A HIGH SCHOOL.
HISTORY TEACHER IN OUR YOUNGEST
GOES TO. NORTHERNER BODY THERE'S
ANY USED UNIVERSITY HE JUST
COMPLETED HIS SOPHOMORE YEAR. SO
I'M VERY THANKFUL AS A SERVICE
OPPORTUNITY I APPRECIATE THE
CENTERS FIND TODAY IS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS FOR. THE
CENTER'S STAFF AS WELL AS
POSTOPERATIVE. THANK YOU AND
CHIEF THANK YOU AND PLEASE
FORGIVE ME AS SOMEONE WITH ALSO
A GENERAL GENDER NEUTRAL NAME I
SHOULD I CALLED YOU MISTER-
PLEASE FORGIVE ME. R. I
APOLOGIZE AND- WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE RESUME I THANK YOU.
LET'S TURN TO- COMMISSIONER ON
ALSO CHIEF- TEEN ANY YET THOUGH
. GOOD MORNING I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE- I'M HONORED TO AND
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY A BE CONSIDERED- AS A
POST COMMISSIONER ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR. FOR MAKING
THE NOMINATION AND A SPECIAL
SHOUT OUT TO MY PARTNER WHO'S
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ME AS-
I'VE BEEN IN POLICING FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS AND SHE'S PUT UP A
LOT- I'M CURRENTLY THE MARINA
POLICE CHIEF. I'VE BEEN HERE
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO
THAT I SPENT OVER TWENTY EIGHT
HALF YEARS WITH LAPD THE LAST
TEN AS A COMMAND OFFICER- HAVING
THE HONOR TO WORK WITH-
OVERSEEING FOUR DIFFERENT
DIVISIONS AND WORKING WITH. FOR
VERY DIFFERENT DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT TIME DID NOT PUT THAT ON
THIS ISLAND. ALL GOOD- YOU KNOW
US SINCE I AM A NEW HI PLEASE.
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MYSELF- I'M CURRENTLY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE MONTEREY
COUNTY OF POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION- I'VE SAT ON MANY
BOARDS- I WAS PRESIDENT OF-
HISPANIC AMERICAN COMMAND
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. SEVERAL
YEARS BACK I ACTUALLY SAT ON THE
BOARD FOR OVER SEVEN YEARS AND
THAT REPRESENTS AN INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION THE OLDEST. HISPANIC
COMMAND OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ARE
IN EXISTENCE- I ALSO- HAVE SAT
ON- FEDERAL TASK FORCE LOOKING
AT ISSUES OF OFFICER WELLNESS-
LOOKING AT A USE OF FORCE-
WASTED THE ESCALATES- THE LAST
ONE WORKING WITH THE DOJ- JUST
LAST YEAR IN THE STUDY JUST CAME
OUT ON THAT. ON WORKING WITH
VIRTUAL REALITY OF HOW WE CAN
BETTER IMPLEMENT THAT INTO OUR
TRAINING- TO LOOK AT BIASES AND
IDEA ESCALATING. IN I'M JUST
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE AND ONE MORE
ON THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
ERIN WHINER HE'S A PHD
CANDIDATE. WHO HELPED IMPLEMENT
A TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE
PROGRAM HERE AT MY- CURRENT
AGENCY- ANY BUT A LOT OF WORK
INTO IT THAT IT REALLY HAS PAID
DIVIDENDS FOR THE MORALE OF THE
AGENCY AND FOR RETENTION
RECRIMINATIONS. AGAIN THANK YOU
TO THE BOARD OFFER HAVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- I WILL. ASK MY
COLLEAGUES SINCE THERE ARE FOUR.
COMMISSIONERS ARE IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS TO- DIRECT THE
QUESTION TO THE SPECIFIC
COMMISSIONER. IF IN FACT THEY
WANT ALL FOR TO ANSWER THEN I
WILL PICK UP THE FACILITATION
AND- MIX IT UP A BIT SO
EVERYBODY GETS GETS A CHANCE TO.
GO FIRST AND NOT ALWAYS BE PUT
ON THE SPOT TO ANSWER FIRST SO-
I WILL START WITH SENATOR COM
LONGER WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK US
OFF. YES SURE THANK YOU- MADAM
PRO TEM AND I WILL I WILL DIRECT
OF MINE- TO THE SPECIFIC.
APPOINTEES I'M SO MY FIRST SO I
WANT TO THANK EACH OF YOU ALL
ALL OF YOU ACTUALLY FOR-
SPENDING SOME TIME WITH ME THE
OTHER DAY- IN PREPARATION FOR
THIS PARTICULAR HEARING- I KNOW
THAT EVERYONE HAS INCREDIBLY
BUSY SCHEDULES I KNOW THAT WE
TALKED QUITE A BIT ABOUT- SB
TWO- THAT WAS A- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT- INVOLVED SO
MANY PEOPLE AND SO MANY
DISCUSSIONS- HAPPENED- IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE BILL AND
WHILE IT WAS CIRCULATING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- AND IT
REALLY ALLOWED PEOPLE TO HAVE
SOME DEEP AND SOMETIMES-
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS AND I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE WAS AND REMAINS AGREEMENT
THAT THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS WHO ARE- EMPLOYED IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ARE SAFE ARE
TRAINED- AND FEEL- THAT THEY
ARE- BEING SUPPORTED BY OTHER
FOLKS ON THE FORCE- AND FOLKS
WHO ARE THEIR SUPERVISORS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO THE BEST JOB THAT THEY CAN'T
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WE WANT
HEALTHY PEOPLE WORKING HEALTH
LEVY- YOU KNOW- ESPECIALLY IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT WORKING TO KEEP
US ALL SAFE. AND SO- MISTER
BARCELONA I ACTUALLY HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU. I
WANTED TO KNOW- WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE RETROACTIVITY OF
S. B. TWO- BECAUSE I KNOW. THAT
MANY FOLKS HAVE SORT OF RAISED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THIS
WILL MEAN FOR NOT JUST POST BUT
ALSO FOR HOW WE WORK TOWARDS-
MEANINGFUL DECERTIFICATION. I
THINK THAT- THAT'S ALSO GOING TO
BE A LEGAL QUESTION THAT HAS.
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOME INSTANCES THAT WERE
INVESTIGATED BY THE- FBI THE
CALAVERAS GENERAL AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND THEY WERE
CLEARED AND ALL THREE OF THOSE
AGENCIES. AND IF THE IF
SOMEONE'S PICKED OUT OF THAT IT
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
LEGAL CHALLENGE AND- IT'S YET TO
BE ANSWERED- I'VE HAD THESE.
THESE KIND OF QUESTIONS COME UP
TO ME FROM- FROM OFFICERS IN THE
FIELD- SOME OF THEM WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSOCIATION AND
PRESIDENT OF AS WELL. AND THERE
THEY HAVE ASKED THE SAME
QUESTION I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
REALLY KNOW THE TOTAL ANSWER TO
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE ADJUDICATED AND- AND
DECIDED IN THE COURTS. OKAY AND
HOW WOULD HOW WOULD HOW WOULD
YOU DEFINE SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
WELL YOU KNOW WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THIS- THE LAST MEETING AND
YOUR- I THINK YOU KNOW THAT THE
BILL HAS. HAS THE ITEMS THERE
THAT TO YOU KNOW THAT WE CARE
THAT THAT THAT THE SENATE CARED
ABOUT IN THE GOVERNMENT CARES
ABOUT. THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
DISCUSSION- THIS GOING AROUND
SERIOUSNESS CONDUCT WHAT THAT
IS. AND YOU'LL EVER WANT TO LOOK
UP THE- THE YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WHAT IT WHAT IT SAYS IN THE
DICTIONARY BUT I KNOW THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF. OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT I KNOW THAT POSTED
SKEWS ME A PHONE JUST KEEPS
RINGING HERE I TRY TO LIVE IS
STILL DOING THAT- AND THERE'S-
QUESTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC A LOT
OF. PEOPLE WANT TO GIVE INPUT ON
WHAT THEY FEEL ABOUT THAT AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
THAT BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO HEAR
EVERY. POSSIBLE IF PINION ABOUT
WHAT WHAT IT IS BEFORE THE
COMMISSION FINALLY MAKES A
DECISION ON. OF THE L. ONE
TRADER THOUGHT IS TO HAVE SOME
LEEWAY THERE SO THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT. EACH CASE YOU LOOK AT
THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THEN TRY TO
APPLY. THE OF THESE-
REQUIREMENTS TO THAT. END AND
THEN OUR OTHER PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO NARROW IT AND SO I'D LIKE TO
HEAR ALL THE OPINIONS ABOUT IT
BEFORE I MAKE A FINAL DECISION.
HAHA AND- DO YOU HOW DO YOU
BECAUSE THIS WAS ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT CAME UP. YOU KNOW
OF WHICH IS HOW DO WE HOLD
MEMBERS OF OUR OWN TRIBE
ACCOUNTABLE. AND DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING I MEAN HOW
DO YOU THINK THAT WHAT ROLE DO
YOU THINK POST. PLAYS IN MATH
AND HOW- DO YOU THINK POST CAN
PLAY A BETTER ROLE. IN THAT. ALL
IT'S ACCOUNT. ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT A HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE IN
THE OFFICE WHILE THE OFFICERS
BUT I MEAN IF COMMISSIONERS ARE
DOING SHADY STUFF I GUESS THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO OF
COURSE ALL OF WELL YOU'RE
TALKING TO ME AND SOME OF US ARE
PEACE OFFICERS AND SO ON SO YEAH
WELL WE OBVIOUSLY WERE ALL HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND ALL THE POLICIES AND POST
PROCEDURES BUT I THINK.
EVERYBODY THAT I'VE MET ON THIS
CONDITIONS EXTREMELY DEDICATED
TO DOING THE RIGHT THING AND
FOLLOWING ALL OF THE LEGISLATION
RULES SIX SEVEN WITHOUT HOST
HOUSES WELL M. YOU KNOW IF
ANYTHING THERE'S PROBABLY A LOT
OF US WHO REALLY WANT TO READ
AND KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT ANY
CASE THAT FLOW OF RAW OF
POSSIBLE WRONGDOING SO THAT WE
MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE DECISION.
I THINK THAT EVERYBODY ON THE
COMMISSION VERY COMMITTED TO
THAT INCLUDING MYSELF AND I
THINK EVERYONE IS HONEST AND
FORTH WITH THEM AND WANTS TO DO
THAT SO I THINK WE'RE IN A
REALLY GOOD SPOT AT THE FOLKS-
THAT WE- WORK WITH OPPOSE STUCK
MISTER DISSOLVED MENTIONED BANNY
AND EVERYBODY THERE THEY'RE
EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE THE STAFF
THE POST HOUSING HIGH- THE HIGH
BAR THAT- POST HAS FOR THEM SO I
THINK THAT- WEREN'T A VERY GOOD
POSITION WITH STAFF AND COMMIT.
TO YOUR- IT CAN THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU I JUST HAVE ONE- I
HAVE A QUICK ACT FOR CHIEF
GORDEN WHICH IS. I'D LOVE TO
KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON GETTING-
ON BECOMING AREN'T GETTING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE BEFORE
BECOMING AN OFFICER IN A WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE NOW
HAPPENING THAT- OFFICER SHOULD
HAVE BE AS- AND IF WE GET IT.
YEAH I THINK EDUCATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS BUT I DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
A QUALIFIER TO BECOME A POLICE
OFFICER. I THINK THAT THEY NEED
TO SHOW A COUNTY NEED TO SHOW
THAT THEY HAVE SOME EDUCATION AS
IT LEAST STARTED. THEIR
EDUCATION- BECAUSE I DO THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT BUT NOT
EVERYONE HAS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES. AND SO I THINK
THAT WE LIMITS SOME OF THE POOL
OF APPLICANTS THAT WE HAVE. IF
WE DON'T ALLOW FOR EDUCATION TO
HAPPEN CONTINUOUSLY ONCE THEY
BECOME A POLICE OFFICER. YOU
KNOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
INCENTIVES THAT WE OFFER AS AN
AGENCY IS THAT WE PAY FOR
FURTHER EDUCATION. WHO WILL PAY
FOR THEIR TUITION THEY GIVE
THOSE THAT MAY NOT HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE- TO COMPLETE
THAT. THE WE HAVE CANDIDATES
THAT COME IN THAT OR FROM
MINORITY FAMILIES WHO ARE
ACTUALLY THE PRIMARY SUPPORTERS
OF THEIR FAMILIES. AND THEY
HAVEN'T HAD THE SAME-
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMPLETE THEIR
BACHELOR'S DEGREE WHEN THEY COME
IN. SO I THINK THAT YES
EDUCATIONS IT CAN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT BUT I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE A QUALIFIER BY ITSELF. WERE WHETHER OR NOT WE HIGHER
NOT LOOKING. GREAT BUT MY UNDER
IS THAT YOU MANY OF YOUR
OFFICERS ALL HAVE THE IS TO BE A
DEGREE. MANY OF MY OFFICERS DO
IN FACT THAT BA DEGREES IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ENCOURAGE AND
I ACTUALLY HAVE SEVERAL OFFICERS
THAT HAVE THEIR MASTER'S DEGREES
. BUT IN TERMS OF IT BEING A
DISQUALIFIER. I AM NOT IN IN
FAVOR OF IT BEING A DISQUALIFIER
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT I
CLEARLY BELIEVE IN EDUCATION I
HAVE AN EDUCATION. BUT I ALSO
KNOW THAT. YOU DON'T MY WIFE
DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I DID AND SHE
WENT BACK LATER IN LIFE AND
AFTER TAKING ONE CLASS AT A TIME
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME. WHEN
BACKING A BENCH LEE GOT HER
BACHELOR'S AND HER MASTER'S
DEGREE AND THEN HER LICENSE TO
PRACTICE SO I THINK THAT
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT PATH.
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION WORN WORK LOOKING
AT WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE. I
THANK YOUNG MAN PART TIME I JUST
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION ACTUALLY
FOR- MISS NATO CHIEF YES YES OF
COURSE PART OF ME WANTS TO ASK
HER ABOUT- HER ALBUMS AND HIT
RECORDS YOU KNOW TINA MARIE- BUT
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE YOU KNOW-
BUT OUT OF THE SCOPE OF. ITS
FIRST ACTION THAT'S RIGHT THIS
COMMITTEE YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
BUDGET MANTLE YOU- AS WELL AS
CHIEF GORDON HAVE OUR CHIEF OF
SMALLER CITIES BUT YOU'VE ALSO
SPENT A PORTION OF YOUR CAREER
WITH LAPD WHICH IS A VERY LARGE-
POLICING CITY AND- AS IT RELATES
TO SORT OF WHAT YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
HOW YOU'VE BEEN- SORT OF. YOU
KNOW PRIMED FOR A SERVING ON
POST AND THE WORK THAT YOU ALL
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING AS IT
RELATES TO TRAINING AND YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING CULTURE CHANGE WITHIN
DEPARTMENTS. AND THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS AND WHAT
MISCONDUCT LOOKS LIKE DO YOU
HAVE ANY SORT OF INSIGHT ON DO
YOU BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCES OF
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN POLICING
SMALL CITIES AND POLICING IN
LARGE CITIES AND WHAT. INSIGHT
YOU HAVE THAT WILL BE HELPFUL TO
YOU OR THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
LEAN ON- WITH SOME OF THESE YOU
KNOW OUR DISCUSSIONS AROUND THAT
YOU HOW WE MANAGE- MISCONDUCT IN
TRAINING AND STANDARDS. IN JUST
ONE. YEAH I JUST NAY THAT'S AND
THAT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION-
YOU KNOW ON ON TOP OF IT LET ME
ADD THAT I'M ALSO AN ARMY
VETERAN- I WAS A CAPTAIN IN THE
ARMY SO I ALSO AROUND SMALL
LARGE UNITS ON THERE AND HAD TO
DO ON WITH TRAINING ALSO BECAUSE
TRAINS A VERY IMPORTANT KEY TO
ANY ORGANIZATION TO KEEP IT
RUNNING AND KEEP IT HEALTHY- BUT
IT BUT IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
COMING FROM A LARGE AGENCY THE
LAST TEN YEARS WITH THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT. I
ACTUALLY WAS A COMMANDING
OFFICER SURROUND LARGE PARTS OF
THE CITY- IT WAS LIKE BEING A
CHIEF OF A LARGE CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND LAPD BEING TEN
THOUSAND SWORN OFFICERS I KNOW
THEY'RE DOWN ABOUT NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED BECAUSE THEY HIRINGS A
LITTLE DIFFICULT BUT- WHEN YOU
COME FROM A VERY LARGE AGENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO TRAINING THEY
CAN DEDICATE PEOPLE- TO WORK
CERTAIN JOBS TO HELP TRAIN
OFFICERS SO YOU HAVE COMPLETE
TRAINING UNITS- AND THEY DO A
LOT OF THE WORK- IS TO KEEP UP
ON THE TRAINING THAT COMES OUT
OF POSTED. AND ANY OTHER
MANDATES THAT THAT COME OUT OF
EITHER THE STATE OR ON A FEDERAL
LEVEL AND SO FOR BIG AGENCIES
IT'S KIND OF PACKAGED UP FOR YOU
ARE COMING TO LITTLE AGENCY MY
FIRST WORDS WERE WHAT DO YOU
MEAN I HAVE TO DO MY OWN WORK
AND- THAT TRANSLATED INTO WITH
SMALLER AGENCIES IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT. TO KEEP IT SEES
TRAINED AND SO YOU HAVE TO START
LOOKING AT IT FROM A MORE
REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE A REALLY
WITH YOUR- ALLIED AGENCIES TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT YOU CAN
TRAIN- YOU YOU KNOW YOUR FOLKS
IN THERE FOR THE SAME TIME
DOESN'T GET CONSTRAINTS. PERSON
SINCE- YOU KNOW I'LL FORWARD TO
BEING A POST BECAUSE I DO SOME
I. OF HOW WE CAN. THE MEDIUM
SIZE AND SMALLER AGENCIES IN OUR
STATE WHICH ARE THE BALK. OF THE
AGENCIES OR PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- SO DOES
BRING A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OR I
BRING THAT UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE-
TO THE COMMISSION. HAVING SERVED
IN- YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES THAT I HAVE IN THE
PAST. RIGHT THANK YOU AND THOSE
ARE MY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR COME LONGER META VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THIS ONE'S DIFFICULT TO ASK
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND HAVE
EVERYBODY ANSWER SO. I JUST LET
ME SAY FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH- FOR REVIEW FOR STEPPING
FORWARD AND PARTICIPATING IN
WHAT I THINK WE ALL BELIEVED TO
BE A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
SIGNIFICAN IN NEW ROLE ARE THERE
TO BE PLAYING IN THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS. AND I
KNOW ARE YOU SUPPORTED-
COMMISSIONERS BARCELONA REVEAL
LAST TIME I FELT THAT YOUR
SERVICE OVER THE FIFTH AT TIMES
BE AN AUTHOR LEE REMARKABLE YOUR
RESUMES ALL OF YOU REMARKABLE SO
ARE YOU- ANYONE IS OPEN TO
ANSWER MY QUESTION AND IT'S
GOING BACK TO THE- THE- OF. OUR
DECERTIFICATION AND
SPECIFICALLY. WE WHEN WE REVIEW
HERE LET'S SAY- COMPLAINTS ABOUT
WORK FORCE CONDUCTIN OUR- IN
OUR CAPITAL- IN IN OUR- WITH ALL
OF OUR EMPLOYEES AND CERTAINLY
ON OUR LEGISLATORS ALSO THERE'S
A PROCESS THERE'S A STRUCTURE
THAT THE COMPLAINT GOES THROUGH.
IS THERE ANY CONSTRUCT SURE
THAT'S ON YOUR MIND OR THAT IS
COMING THROUGH FROM THE
TRANSITION TEAM OF HOW OLD THE
COMPLAINTS WILL BE RECEIVED AND
GO THROUGH A THIRD GOING TO BE A
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE OR IS IT
GOING TO BE ALL OF YOU AT THE
SAME TIME LOOKING AT IT AND
ASKING QUESTIONS TO. OBVIOUSLY
IF STAFF THAT WILL BRING IT TO
YOU COULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
PROCESS BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE FINAL OUTCOME
ON EACH AND EVERY COMPLAINT AND-
ALLEGATION AND THEN YOUR
DECISION OF WHETHER THERE'S A
DECERTIFICATION OF THAT
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL. SO LET ME
ASK YOU MIGHT WANT TO TACKLE
THAT FIRST JUST GONNA RAISE YOUR
HAND AND ALL RECOGNIZE YOU-
THANK YOU- MISTER BRAZIL GO
AHEAD. I'LL GO FIRST AND ZERO
THREE BOND- SO THIS THIS
LEGISLATION COUNTED- DEFINES THE
STRUCTURE ITSELF OR HOW IT WORKS
ITS WAY THROUGH THE WHOLE
SYSTEM- HOW IT WORKS ITS WAY
THROUGH THE POST COMMISSION
SYSTEM. IS GOING TO BE VERY
MUCH- RELY ON STAFF PRESENTED
HER PACKAGE TO US WE HAD AS THE
COMMISSION A LOT OF GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT DO WE BECAUSE
OF THE VOLUME MORE ANTICIPATING
IN THE VOLUME OF THE FUTURE YOU
WERE GREAT SUB COMMITTEES AND IT
WAS I DON'T SPEAK FOR ALL THE
COMMISSIONERS BUT I GOT A
UNIVERSAL LIVE WITH THAT. NOW IF
WE CAN MAKE DECISIONS ON
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD WE WANT TO
ACTUALLY READ THE ENTIRE IT'S
NOT SUMMARIES BACHELOR THE FAX-
I KNOW IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVES
OF THE ROOM THEY'RE PART OF THE
POST COMMISSION THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO AS THEIR STANDARD
PRACTICE THEY DON'T ACCEPT
SERVICE DISCIPLINE UNEMPLOYED
I'M ACTUALLY READING THE CASE
SINCE. SOME CHALLENGING
SOMETIMES A FAX OR IN THE CASE
AND OR THE LEVEL INVESTIGATION
SO HOW I SEE IT WORKING FOR THE
POST SYSTEM OF STAFF TRACKING
MONITORING THE ALL THE
BACKGROUND COLLECTING THE DATA
COLLECTING THE REPORTS AND THEN
PUSH IT OUT TO US AS
COMMISSIONERS. FIRST TO THEN
REVIEW AND THEN HAVE MEANING
SPECIFIC TO OUR SEGMENTS MEANING
SPECIFIC TO INDIVIDUAL CASES FOR
ALL OF THE COMMISSIONERS ARE
WELL VERSED IN THAT CASE ON IN
EITHER CHALLENGE STAFF TO GO
BACK AND GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OR CONTINUE ON IN
THE PROCESS. OF THIS IS GOING TO
BE ONE OF THOSE IT'S NEW TO US-
IT'S NEW TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE GONNA FIND
HICCUPS ALONG THE WAY REUNIFY
NEED TO COME BACK THE
LEGISLATURE AND SAY LISTEN WE'VE
IDENTIFIED SOME ISSUES WITH IN
THE LEGISLATION MIGHT YOU BE
FINE TUNING- THAT ALLOW THE
PROCESS TO MOVE MORE SMOOTHLY.
FOR EVERYONE OF ALL. THE OPPOSED
TO THE CAN. TO THE- EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE GOING TO THE PROCESS. OF
GOING THROUGH THIS CARE PROCESS-
TO STREAMLINE IT SO A LOT OF
THIS IS ON PAPER NOW. I'M VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT STAFF HAS
PRESENTED A POST IN THE
PROCESSES CAN BE PUSHED FORWARD.
I- I KNOW THAT- DIRECTOR ALVAREZ
AND HIS SENIOR STAFF AND
DEDICATED FULL TIME STAFF TO
THIS FROM THE GET GO- THEY'VE
BEEN PULLED OFF OF OTHER. TASKS
INPUT ON THIS TO DEVELOP THIS
BECAUSE OF THE TIGHT TIME LINE-
SO. WHAT I CAN DESCRIBE IT IS
THE FRAMEWORK OF WHAT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING BUT I TOTALLY
EXPECT YOU'LL HEAR BACK FROM US-
REQUESTING SOME. KIND OF
TWEAKING THE LEGISLATION ALLOW
THE PROCESS TO MOVE MORE
SWIFTLY. THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT
WAS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS TO YOU
THAT WOULD YOU BE COMING BACK AS
YOU WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS TO
THE LEGISLATURE. I TO TWEAK IT
HERE AND THERE SO THAT TIME.
THIRDLY THAT ANSWERS THAT
QUESTION I'D LIKE THE REST OF
YOU INDIVIDUALLY- TO. COMMENT ON
HOW YOU'RE FEELING LAW
COMFORTABLE THAT THE STRUCTURE
DOES. DOES SUPPORT THE DUE
PROCESS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
THE COMPLAINT HAS BEEN- YOU KNOW
PROMULGATED AGAIN STAND UP I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CAME
UP IN THE ON STAFF INTERVIEWS
ABOUT PROTECTING DUE PROCESS.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
pWANT TO BE OF COMPARABLE WITH
THAT. IS YOU FEEL BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE THE FINAL DECISION
MAKERS ON F. JUST A QUICK
COMMENT FROM EACH ONE OF YOU ON.
THE STRUCTURE AND ALL WHETHER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE THAT YET HAS
THE GREATEST PROTECTION. FOR THE
DUE PROCESS THAT'S OBVIOUSLY.
NOT REQUIRED FOR BOTH SIDES OF.
OF ANY COMPLAINT I THOUGHT CHIEF
NETTERS HAND FIRST WE'LL START
WITH YOU CHIEF OF THAT'S OKAY
AND THEN I'LL WORK MY WAY.
ACROSS I THINK YOU OF TINA AND
TINA NIETO- YES THIS IS A BIG
DISCUSSION ACTUALLY AT OUR LAST
MEETING IN WHEN WE'RE- LOOKING
AT DEFINITIONS AND TALKING ABOUT
THE PROCESS IN FACT OUR LAST
SEVERAL MEETINGS. I'M LOOKING AT
S. B. TWO- I KNOW FOR THE REST
OF THE BOARD FROM LISTENING TO
THEIR COMMENTS THAT DUE PROCESS
IS VERY IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY
FOR THE COMMAND LEVEL- SWORN
PERSONNEL THAT SIT ON THE BOARD.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO PROTECT THE
DUE PROCESS PROBAR. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY I COMMISSIONER RESULT
TALKED ABOUT WE WERE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT WE NEED TO SEE.
THE ENTIRE CASE AND I SAY THAT
TO HIM. WHEN I WAS WITH THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE I WAS COMMAND OFFICER. I
NOT ONLY DID I HAVE TO LOOK AT-
VERY SERIOUS MISCONDUCT CASES AS
A COMMAND OFFICER TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION. BUT I ALSO SET
OUT ON WHAT THEY CALL THE BORDER
RIGHT IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
WHERE PEOPLE COULD APPEAL THAT.
AND MANY TIMES THE INVESTIGATION
WHEN I SAT ON THE BORDER RIGHTS
THERE IS INFORMATION ON THAT WAS
NOT IN IN THE- CASE- AND THAT.
GAVE ME CONCERN AND THEY WERE
SLEEPING SWEAR THAT
RECOMMENDATION MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TERMINATION FOR US IS POSTED
MIGHT BE TO CERTIFICATION. AND
ALL THE INFORMATION WASN'T THERE
I HAVE COMPLETE. O. N. ARM HOST-
WHEN IT COMES FOR TO US BUT BUT
THAT CERTAINLY IS MY CONCERN. I
THE OTHER THING NOW BEEN WITH
THE SMALL AGENCY AND WORKING
WITH OTHER SMALL AGENCIES- HELP
PEOPLE CLASSIFIER- COMPLAINTS IS
DIFFERENT FROM AGENCY TO AGENCY.
AND AS A PROPOSED COMMISSIONER
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE CONSISTENCY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE. ON
HOW WE DO THAT- SO THAT WHEN THE
CASE IS IF THEY DO GO UP TO POST
AND THEY MEET THE MANDATES OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. OR THE NINE
NINE CRITERIA- THAT WE HAVE A
COMPLETED CASE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- I TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY I THINK WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT NOBODY WANTS BAD
ACTORS ARE BAD APPLES AND
POLICE. IN POLICING AND PUBLIC
SAFETY IT MAKES EVERYBODY. LOOK
BAD OF ONE PERSON TARNISHES THE
BADGE IT TARNISHES THE BADGE.
NATIONALLY SO WE DON'T WANT THAT
BUT IN THE SAME RESPECT YOU DO
WANT TO PROTECT. THOSE PEOPLE
WHO. REALLY THEIR LIVES AND
DEDICATED TO PUBLIC SAFETY THAT-
WERE NOT TAKEN AWAY THEIR
LIVELIHOODS- BASED ON BAD
INFORMATION SO AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT
POST WILL GIVE US COMPLETED-
CASES ARE THAT WE CAN MAKE. GOOD
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
DETERMINATIONS WHEN WE VOTE- BUT
THAT HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN AT THE BACK OF MY MIND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
PROCESS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TIME. CHIEF NATURAL OBVIOUSLY I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE ALL ARE
BECAUSE IT'S ANOTHER SORT OF A
CORPORATE PROCEEDINGS. OF THE
LAST QUESTION ON ON DEATH- IS
THE CONFIDENTIAL CONFIDENTIALITY
BECAUSE CERTAINLY WITH OUR WORK
FORCE. COMPLIANCE UNIT HERE WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY ACCOUNT ALWAYS.
ENSURE THAT THERE WON'T BE ON TO
A LITTLE BIT OF- YOU KNOW RUMORS
AND- LEAKS THAT TUB. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S PART OF THE
PROCESS. UP UNTIL THE FINAL
DECISION. TO A SPECIFIC PERSON
OR ALL ANYWAY. WELL I THINK GO
TO NEED TO OKAY. YOU KNOW
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS TO SURE ALL
OK CHIEF YES- WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO PERSONAL ISSUES- YOU KNOW AT
LEAST WITH THE AGENCIES YES IT'S
NOT LATE BUT- I I'M NOT QUITE
SURE HOW CLOSE IS GONNA HANDLE
IT BECAUSE ONCE. THE CASE
ACTUALLY GOES TO POST I BELIEVE
THAT- PUBLIC RECORDS ACT YOU YOU
CAN CTUALLY SUBPOENA THE CASE I
KNOW FROM OTHER CHEESE SAYS AS
WE LOOK AT THIS WITH CAL CHIU
SAID MAYBE- COMMISSIONER GORDON
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I KNOW SHE SITS ON. CAL
CHEESE THERE IS SOME CONCERN
ABOUT- YOU KNOW WHAT ARE GOING
TO BE THE PRIVACY RIGHTS AND
WHAT WILL POST RELEASE OR NOT
RELEASE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS- AGAIN I THINK. SURE
BARCELONA A LOT ABOUT IT I THINK
IT WAS THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT
OF CASE LAW AND A LOT OF
OPINIONS. ON THAT ARE GOING TO
CHANGE THE PROCESS. IN THE
COMING YEARS- JUST BASED ON SOME
OF THE UNANSWERED. QUESTIONS OR
THINGS THAT WE JUST. CAN'T
ANTICIPATE WHEN YOU ARE. PASSED
LEGISLATION LIKE IT'S SB TWO.
JEFF GORDON DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT. BUT I WOULD
APPROVED- CHIEF ME AT THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK WE'VE ALL HAD
THE DISCUSSION OF HOW IMPORTANT
AND HOW SERIOUS WE ALL TAKE THIS
THE CONFIDENTIALITY IS
CERTAINLY- VERY IMPORTANT AND IS
OF A CONCERN BECAUSE THE LAST
THING WE WANT IS FOR THIS TO
BECOME A VOTE OF- PUBLIC
OPINION- OF VERSES. HE VOTED
BASED ON FACTS THAT AND WE TO
TALLY OF THE ENTIRE CASE. SO I
THINK IF THINGS BECOME PUBLIC
INFORMATION BEFORE THAT OCCURS.
THAT CAN BE VERY DANGEROUS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE CASE. IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAINTAIN THAT CONFIDENTIALITY
ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH. THE VOTE
I'M ALL FOR TRANSPARENCY BUT I'M
ALSO FOR DUE PROCESS AND LIKE I
SAID IT NOT JUST BECOMING A- THE
BILL BASED ON LIMITED
INFORMATION SO THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT NOT LEAKING
OF INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY YOU PRIOR TO POST
MAKING A POST MEASURES MAKING A
FINAL DECISION IT'S GOING TO GO
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
TO DO A FULL EVIDENTIARY
HEARING. WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF A BORDER RIGHTS. AND I
THINK THAT'S IT IMPORT STEP IN
THE PROCESS. BECAUSE IT ALSO
THEN IF THERE'S- INFORMATION
THAT HAS BEEN ANSWERED OR YOU
KNOW IN THE CASE OF A USE OF
FORCE THAT THAT'S AN EXCESSIVE
FORCE REALLY BEING ABLE TO FIND
OUT. ADDITIONAL ANSWERS IN TERMS
OF WHAT WAS IN THE OFFICER'S
MIND IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES. THERE
MAY BE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT COMES OUT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. ONE CONCERN I DO HAVE
IS. THE WAY I UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS AT THIS POINT PROPOSED
COMMISSIONERS WILL SEE THE CASE
TWICE. ONCE BECAUSE THE ADVISORY
BOARD WITH JUST THE PRESENTATION
OF THE CASE ITSELF REPORTER
STAFF BASED ON WHAT THEY HAVE.
WEEK PRIOR TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE AND THEN WE'LL SEE IT
AGAIN AFTER THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE. A FOR THE FINAL VOTE
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSIONERS
MAKING A DECISION WITHOUT ALL OF
THE INFORMATION AND THEN
POTENTIALLY. OVERTURNING THEIR
INITIAL DECISION NOW THAT THEY
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION FROM
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE SO.
THAT YOU KNOW IS IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS
CORRECTLY AND THAT WOULD BE ONE
CONCERN I HAVE IN TERMS OF
REALLY DID YOU ACCESS AND- THE-
JOB OF THE COMMISSIONERS. WELL
THANK YOU FOR THOSE-
EXCEPTIONALLY THOUGHTFUL ANSWERS
TO THAT VERY DIFFICULT QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY. YOU KNOW IN THE FUTURE
AND TO SEE HOW IT FOR WORKING
THAT I'M COMFORTABLE THAT YOU
ALL ARE. REALLY HAVE YOUR HEART
CHEN KNOCK. CERTAINLY YOUR OWN
ON LEVEL OF. SERVICE PREVIOUS
LEVEL OF SERVICE YOU COME TO THE
OFFICE WITH A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE
AND I CERTAINLY I THINK A VERY
VERY SINCERE. EFFORT TO BE VERY
FAIR OFFER TO BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION THAT YOU'LL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH. FULL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WILL BE ON CERTAINLY
IN SUPPORT. MAN ADVICE HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IN THANKS TO MY TWO COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE ONE OF THE TWO THINGS I
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT WAS
THE DECERTIFICATION AND I THINK.
ON THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
DECERTIFICATION CASES ON THE
CAPACITY IN PROCESS TO DO IT.
YOU BOTH WENT THROUGH THAT VERY
WELL. SO MY OTHER- CONCERN THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ABOUT IN IN
GROUPS OF TWO I THANK. IT HAS TO
DO WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF-
S. B. TWO THIRTY ON THE USE OF
FORCE. AND M. ALL START WITH THE
TO OUR POLICE CHIEFS THE TWO
NEWEST MEMBERS BECAUSE THE FARM. YOU'RE SEEING THIS FROM BOTH
SIDES GET YOUR- YOU'RE MEMBERS
OF POST THAT HAS TO IMPLEMENT.
OF USE OF FORCE TRAINING AND
UNIFOR'S UNIFORM N OF MOM USE
OF FORCE GUIDELINES BUT NOW
THEY'VE BEEN IN PLACE FOR A YEAR
WHEN YOU'RE BOTH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT HAS TO
IMPLEMENT THEM AND- I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU DETERMINE
WHETHER THE TRAINING IS
EFFECTIVE. AND WHETHER YOU
BELIEVE THE GUIDELINES ARE BEING
FOLLOWED BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I THINK UP I'D
START WITH CHIEF GORDON AND
CHIEF NAFTA. I THINK THE WE ARE
ALL- WORKING THROUGH THIS WE
HAVE STARTED IMPLEMENTING AND
THIS OUR DEPARTMENT WE STARTED
IMPLEMENTING IMMEDIATELY IN
TERMS OF UPDATING OUR USE OF
FORCE POLICIES OR USE OF FORCE
TRAINING- WE'VE ACTUALLY. GONE
BACK TO DOING OUR IN HOUSE
TRAINING BECAUSE WE WANT TO HAVE
SOME QUALITY CONTROL SO WE HAVE
OUR OWN USE OF FORCE INSTRUCTORS
AND HAVE BEEN GETTING OUR OWN
CERTIFIED WE'VE BEEN-
IMPLEMENTING THE TRAINING TO
DIFFERENT PLACES WERE TRACKING
OR DE ESCALATION. THE WORLD
LOOKING ORDER USES OF FORCE
DIFFERENTLY IN TERMS OF. WHAT
KIND OF FORCE ARE WORSE ARE WE
ARE TYPICALLY SEEN ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IN TERMS
OF TRAINING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CORRECTING ANY OF THESE
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH THE NEW-
YOU SUPPORT STANDARDS AND- AND I
THINK IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A
CULTURAL CHANGE. AND IT'S L.
MAKING THAT SHIFT IN HELPING
OFFICERS UNDERSTAND THAT. IT'S
NOT THAT THEY CANNOT USE FORCE
BUT IT'S THE EXPECTATIONS OF
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
CANNED AND HOW THEY DO THAT AND-
THE- THE WAY THAT THE
ESCALATION. IS INVOLVED IN THAT.
SO I THINK IT'S AN ON GOING
PROCESS I THINK THAT. PART OF IT
IS HOW WE COMMUNICATED TO OUR
OFFICERS BECAUSE JUST. LOOKING
AT IT B. O. S. CAN YOU GIVE THEM
ALL A BIT OF PAUSE ON. YOUR
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN- IF I USE
FORCE. AND THEY HAVE TO KNOW
THAT THEY CAN WHEN IT'S- WHEN
THE SITUATION CALLS FOR IT
BECAUSE THE LAST THING WE ALSO
DON'T WANT TO SEE IS OFFICERS
GETTING HURT. BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T TAKEN ACTION SO I THINK
THAT WE ARE DOING A BETTER JOB
OF HELPING OUR OFFICERS
UNDERSTAND THE ESCALATION WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE. FROM WHAT
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM
IT'S A LOT OF IT IS HELPING THEM
SLOW DOWN AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE TIME WHEN THEY DO AND
THEY DON'T ALWAYS. BUT IT'S PART
OF THAT DECISION MAKING PROCESS
IT'S PART OF DOING CRITICAL
INCIDENT DEBRIEFS YOU KNOW WE'VE
GONE TO BODY CANCERS IN CAR CAM
SO THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REALLY SIT BACK AND LOOK AT SOME
INCIDENTS. AND DO IT IN A WAY
WERE FEEDBACK IS ACCEPTED AND
IT'S NOT UNITS. SO THAT WE CAN
BECOME BETTER BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S ALSO. A BIG COMPONENT OF
IT IS LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN BE
BETTER AND NOT ALWAYS DENIED IT
IN TERMS OF OUR PUNITIVE- THERE
ARE SOMETIMES IT THAT DISCIPLINE
IS WARRANTED. BUT ALSO LOOKING
AT IT IN TERMS OF LEARNING AND
TEACHING WE CAN'T MISS THAT
POINT BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT NOW. WE'VE GONE
BACK TO HAVING OUR OWN IN HOUSE
YES OF COURSE INSTRUCTORS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT- YOU
KNOW. MOVING ACROSS THE MAT TEN
TIMES ARE DOING THINGS IT'S
ABOUT HOW WE APPLY FORCE AND
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS IS MORE
IMPORTANT. THAN HOW WE'RE
TRAINING OUR OFFICERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE PER. THE VETR. A
METAL AND- BY THE WAY IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU. I THINK YOU'RE ON
THE YEAH. I THINK YOU'RE ON MUTE
. AT THE W. I GOTTA KEEP
REMEMBERING THE HIT THAT SECOND
BUTTON SO ON UP ON SB TWO
THIRTY- I LOOK AT IT A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY- I DO BELIEVE
THAT IN LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WE
WERE DOING A LOT OF THESE THINGS
BEFORE THE LAW WAS EVEN
IMPLEMENTED AS FAR AS USE OF
FORCE POLICIES- WE ARE WE ARE
ALREADY INCORPORATING ON BIASES
IMPLICIT BIASES EXPLICIT BIASES-
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE- SPIN
AROUND FOR ABOUT. THREE YEARS
NOW AND A LOT CHANGED ON THAT
AND SO THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK
THAT- WITH WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
USE FORCE IN THIS WAS HAPPENING.
IN OUR AGENCIES INCLUDING- MY
PRIOR AGENCY AND NOW WITH BRING
UP DEPARTMENTS. THE REQUIREMENT
TO START REPORTING I THINK THAT-
THE EDUCATION PIECE WAS TO
EXPLAIN TO THE OFFICERS THIS IS
A REQUIREMENT AND WE'RE
REPORTING STUFF- THAT MEETS
THOSE STANDARDS THAT THE STATUS
AS THE SHALL BE REPORTED. I
GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN AND MAYBE
I'M ONE OF THESE COMMISSIONERS
THAT HAVE A LOT OF CONCERN AND-
MAYBE I THINK ABOUT THESE
ISSUES. WAY TOO MUCH- IS THAT
ALL AGENCIES ARE REPORTING UNDER
THE STANDARDS AND NOT
INTERPRETING USES OF FORCE IN A
WAY THAT IT MAY NOT BE REPORTED
. BECAUSE CAN'T TRACK THE
METRICS PIECE THAT- IT YOU CAN.
AS FAR FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS HOW DO YOU MAKE THE
PROCESS BETTER OR DO WE NEED TO
TRY PEOPLE. OR OR WHAT'S
STICKING WHAT'S NOT STICKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY CONCERNED
ABOUT ARE OR HOW THEY FEEL THE
WHOLE TRUST PEACE THE WHOLE
PROCEDURAL JUSTICE PIECE OF IT.
I GUESS I LOOK AT IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE- BECAUSE I'M ALSO A
POLICE PERFORMANCE AUDITOR. ON
AND SO I KNOW LIKE N A REGIONAL
LEVEL- WITH MY CURRENT AGENCY-
WE ASKED ACTUALLY ASKED HER
INSURANCE CARRIER- TO COME IN
AND HIGHER INDEPENDENT AUDITOR.
ACTUALLY TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE- GUIDELINES ACTUALLY UNDER
S. B. TWO THIRTY AND THEN ALSO
ON OTHER HIGH RISK ISSUES. OF
WHERE WE CAN DO BETTER. AND
QUITE HONESTLY I THINK WE ALL
FOUND THINGS OUT- FOR THE
SMALLER AGENCIES BECAUSE AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO WEAR MANY DIFFERENT
HATS AND THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
HALF THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT. A
SO YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT
OVERLOOK MY USE OF FORCE BEFORE
IT EVEN GETS INTO MY INBOX ARE
ALSO MY PATROL SERGEANTS OR THEY
MAY BE AND IN CHARGE OR
SOMETHING ELSE- SO WE DON'T WANT
TO SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS SO. I
GUESS- AS A COMMISSIONER I'D BE
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS OF WHAT
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY. IS HOW DO
YOU ENSURE THAT YOU ARE
IMPLEMENTING WHAT SB TWO THIRTY
IS GHASTLY DEAL HOST DOES A VERY
GOOD JOB. ON WITH ITS TRAINING
AND PUSHING THE TRAINING OUT.
BUT ONCE THE TRAINING IS PUSHED
OUT OR WE KNOW WHAT THE
REPORTING PROCEDURES ARE. ARE
HOW ARE WE ENSURING THAT
AGENCIES ARE REPORTING CORRECTLY
I GUESS THAT THAT'S MYONLY
CONCERN AS FAR AS THE NEW LAW.
AND MAYBE I'M OVERTHINKING THAT
SENATOR. FROM I DON'T YOU ARE-
OF. OVERTIME ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO THE SUCCESS OF IT
BEING KIM IMPLEMENTED. AND NOW
THE WOMAN ASKED THE OTHER TWO
ARE COMMISSIONERS THE LONGER
TERM ONES. TO WHAT EXTENT DO YOU
THINK THAT THE POST STANDARDS IN
TRAINING PROGRAMS RELATED TO USE
AND FORCE ARE ADEQUATE. AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU THINK THERE
ARE ANY IMPROVEMENTS. OF THAT
MIGHT BE NECESSARY IN AND START
WITH COMMISSIONER BARCELONA AND
THEN GO TO COMMISSIONER PERCY.
THANKS JOHN- I CAN TALK FROM THE
STATE SIDE SINCE I HAVE
THOUSANDS OF THESE OFFICES IN MY
UNIT THAT- BURKE FROM ONE IN THE
STATE TO THE OTHER. SINCE THESE
BILLS HAVE BEEN PASSED AND
IMPLEMENTED THE STATE HAS DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF MAKING SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR INSTRUCTORS-
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT JOB
BOARDS BUREAUS AND DEPARTMENTS-
UNIFORMED AND THAT AGENTS AND-
PLAINCLOTHES. HAVE ALL BEEN- ALL
THAT THOSE INSTRUCTORS HAVE BEEN
TRAINED PROPERLY AND I'VE GONE
AROUND THE STATE TO TRAINING.
WITH ALL THESE VARIOUS AGENCIES
AND MEMBERS AND IT SEEMS TO BE
WORKING OUT VERY WELL EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS. THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS INTENDED AS
AND- EVERYONE IS FINE WITH THE
ESCALATION THEY'RE FINE WITH
LEARNING ANY NEW TECHNIQUES THAT
THEY CAN TO- LESSEN INJURY TO
BOTH- A SUSPECT OR THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW SOME AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT I STILL THINK- YOUR
YOUR BILL DEFENSIVE TACTICS IS A
PERISHABLE SKILL. SOLVE
ANYTHING- MORE TRAINING IS
BETTER THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS
THAT MOST AGENCIES ARE SHORT
STAFFED AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TIME AND POWER TO ROTATE PEOPLE
IN MORE THAN WHAT'S REQUIRED.
AND THE OTHER ONE'S PHYSICAL
FITNESS- YES SOME PEOPLE- COULD
STAY IN BETTER SHAPE THAN THAT
THAT. PRETTY MUCH MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DON'T GET INJURED OR ALL OF
THE SUSPECTS EITHER. BUT IT'S
WORKING OUT PRETTY WELL AND I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY PROBLEMS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE UNIT
SET UP THAT I- AND INVOLVED.
THANK YOU N. DUCKED COMMISSIONER
BRAZIL. GREAT QUESTION AND A BY
WILL REPEAT HAT- THE OTHER
COMMISSIONERS I THINK WHAT WERE
THE PIECES WERE MISSING IN THIS
IS- YEAH REALLY A ROBUST AFTER
ACTION REVIEW PROCESS. OF THE
AGENCIES ARE TAUGHT HOW TO
CRITICALLY ASSESS WHETHER TO USE
OF FORCE OR OTHER TYPES OF
CRITICAL INCIDENTS AND
COMMISSIONER GORDON BROUGHT UP
TO WORD THE ASSESSMENT THE AFTER
ACTION REVIEWS ABOUT LEARNING IN
SEARCHING FOR BETTER OUTCOMES
AND THAT SEARCHING FOR SOMEBODY
DOING SOMETHING WRONG REPEAT YOU
GO TO PUNITIVE DISCIPLINE. AND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS BEING
ABLE TO GET STEP BACK AND ASSESS
OR DID THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TOOLS
TO BELGRADE TRAINED WEATHER
RIGHT COMMANDED CONTROL
STRUCTURES OR THE TOOLS WERE
GIVEN THEM WORKING OR THEY'RE
NOT WORKING- AND TAT'S THAT
PIECE THE U. S. SENATOR ON HOW
DO WE KNOW IF IT'S WORKING OR
NOT UNTIL YOU BUILD A REALLY
ROBUST AFTER ACTION REVIEW
PROCESS THEY CAN KIND OF CAPTURE
THAT DATA. WE'RE GONNA FALL
SHORT- WE'D NOT POST PER SE BUT
THE AGENCIES PROVIDING THE DATA
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM WE COLLECTED DATA ON THE
OUTCOMES SO TO SPEAK BUT NOT ON
THE DETAILS OF THE EVENT- THE
OTHER PIECE WE'RE STARTING THAT
THIS THIS WAY AND AGAIN ALL
THREE COMMISSIONERS MENTIONED.
IT THIS IS ALL ABOUT DECISION
MAKING- YOU KNOW PERSONAL SKILLS
ARE. YOUR MUSCLE MEMORY BUT
REALLY WHAT WE'RE WE'RE FOR. ON
IS WE NEED FOR ON HIS DECISION.
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE. OF ANY
ACADEMIES- OFFICERS AFTER SHOW
THAT THEY CAN SAFELY HAVE A
WEAPON. AND THAT THEY CAN SAFELY
HAD A TARGET IN THE THAT THEY'VE
QUALIFY BASICALLY BASED ON
NUMBER BROWN'S IF THE TARGET. AN
ANNUAL WE GO BACK AND DO THE
SAME EXACT THING- AND BUT WE
DON'T. GIVE THEM SCENARIOS WHERE
THEY DON'T SHOOT- BUT OTHERS DO
AROUND THEM OR ON IT'S NOT ABOUT
NUMBER HOW MANY TIMES THAT THE
YOU HIT THE TARGET BUT IT'S
ABOUT. DECISION MAKING ACTUALLY
SHOOT AT THE TARGET- AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO. INTEGRATE
THAT CAN DECISION MAKING INTO
USES OF FORCE WERE. USED TO
DIVORCE IS IT USED- I CAN
ARRANGE FOR SOME PEOPLE MAY
SHOOTING SOME PEOPLE MAY NOT. ON
THE SAME LINE OF FIRE TO CREATE
SCENARIOS SOURCE NOT ABOUT
MUSCLE MEMORY IT'S ABOUT
DECISION MAKING- AND THOSE
THINGS COME OUT AFTER ACTION
REVIEWS. IN THE PROCESS SO IT'S-
IT'S COMPLICATED IT'S NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL IT'S NOT ONE THING
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IT'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION ON A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING- AND THAT'S WERE. YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE WE CAN HOPEFULLY
START PARTNERING WITH SOME OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES WE DO ALREADY.
BUT HOW DO WE START LOOKING AT
FROM AN ACADEMIC PERSPECTIVE.
RETURN OF THE VALIDATE THE
CHANGES ARE BEING MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THEN INTO THE
AGENCIES ARE. REALLY HAVING A
POSITIVE EFFECT. WELL THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY DANCER. FOR ALL FOR A
FEW. FOUGHT AND THERE WERE WIDE
RANGING AND- I THINK THE
IMPORTANT THING OUT OF THIS
HEARING IS JUST. ARE YOU WE ARE
JUST VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF- OF SOME OF
THESE LAWS THEIR LANDMARK IN
MANY WAYS AND WE KNOW THAT. THAT
A LITTLE BIT OF IT IS NEW GROUND
IT AND THE WORK THAT YOU DO BUT-
I JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I WILL- AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES OF INCREDIBLE
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES ANA.
LOOKING AT A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WITH A VERY. AMAZING RANGE OF
EXPERIENCES AND TRAINING AND
DECADES OF WORK- IT'S
IMPRESSIVE- FRANKLY YOU KNOW AS
THE RULES COMMITTEE WE- CONFIRM
APPOINTMENTS TODAY WE HAPPEN TO
HAVE FOR INDIVIDUALS TO FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO NEW
APPOINTMENTS ALL FROM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE. THERE ARE
THOSE THAT SERVE ON POSTED JUST
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE PUBLIC-
WHO ARE PUBLIC MEMBERS- THEY
DON'T EXACTLY HAVE A DIRECT LINK
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT I WOULD
SAY- YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE
IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU ALREADY
DO IN YOUR DAILY LIVES ON NODE
CHEAPER SO YOU'RE RETIRED AS A
CHIEF BUT- I JUST IS THE
EXPERTISE TO PROVIDE FOR US AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT. THE ALL OF
YOU MADE REFERENCE AT ONE POINT
OR ANOTHER DURING RESPONDED TO
MY COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS OR OR
COMMENTS TO THE CULTURE SHIFT.
AND I CANNOT EVEN BEGIN TO
IMAGINE WHAT THAT MUST BE LIKE
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE SERVED
DECADES IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THAT SHIFT AND HOW HARD IT IS.
VICE CHAIR MADE REFERENCE TO
CULTURE SHIFT HERE IN OUR OWN
INSTITUTION AND HOW DIFFICULT
THAT HAS BEEN FOR US IS WE
ADDRESS ISSUES- OF PROFESSIONAL
BEHAVIOR. AMONG STAFF AND HOW WE
INTERACT SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR-
FOR YOUR ROLE IN THIS  DON'T
REALLY HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS I
THINK THE BIG ISSUES ARE. WHAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE DISCUSS SB
TWO- THE USE OF FORCE I WOULD
SAY- YOU KNOW WE GET TO ASK
THESE QUESTIONS IS A RULES
COMMITTEE WHEN PEOPLE GET
APPOINTED AND RE APPOINTED AND
CONFIRMED BUT- IT WILL BE OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE- THAT
MAY FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
HEARINGS- YOU KNOW TO FIND OUT
HOW THINGS ARE GOING
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
CULTURE SHIFT IN THE NEW. LAWS
AND LEGISLATION THAT WE PUT INTO
PLACE THAT YOU AS MEMBERS OF
POST. REALLY FOCUS ON IN TERMS
OF TRAINING. I WOULD ASK AS YOU
EVALUATE THIS BECAUSE YOU ALL
SEEM TO TAKE IT- INCREDIBLY
SERIOUSLY. THAT IF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR-
IMPLEMENTATION FOR TWEAKS TO
LEGISLATION. YEAH WE WOULD
ENTERTAIN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU ARE
STAFF- I WOULD LIKE THIS I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES AGREE WE WOULD
LIKE THIS TO BE A PARTNERSHIP IN
A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE-
CONTINUE TO DO BETTER. SUPPLIED
THE SPORT THAT YOU NEED IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TRAINING AND AT
THE SAME TIME HAVE THE EXPECT
REALISTIC EXPECTATION THAT
CULTURE CHANGE DOES NEED TO
HAPPEN AND- I THOUGHT I FEEL
WELL SERVED. BY WHAT I'VE HEARD-
TODAY SO. I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL. IT'S BEEN A IT'S YOU KNOW
ENLIGHTENING AND REALLY GOOD TO
SIT THROUGH AND LISTEN TO THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN YOUR THOUGHTS SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT. WITH THAT I
THINK WE WILL GO AHEAD TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE WILL START WITH
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN PERSON-
ANYONE IN SUPPORT I DO NOT SEE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- HERE SO I
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. AND REMIND
FOLKS THAT WE HAVE A TOLL FREE
NUMBER. THAT IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
MODERATOR TODAY AND ASK IF. THEY
WOULD OPEN THE LINES AND T. UP
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO PLEASE. AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING ON THE TFF I COULD ASK
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. GIVE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY
THAT YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR ARE
INCREDIBLY BRIEF COMMENTS. WE
HAVE A LONG- HEARING A LONGER
HEARING AND MORE APPOINTMENTS TO
COME. GO AHEAD MR MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO PARTICIPANTS IN Q. WHILE
OKAY- WITH THAT THANK YOU WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
MOMENT- WE GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION I ALREADY
KNOW THAT THEIR- IT DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SO
MISSED RIGHT OR I'M GONNA COME
BACK TO YOU AND ASK IF YOU WILL
T. PEOPLE UP THAT MAY WE SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONCE AGAIN THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THIS IS A GOOD SIGN. I
THINK IT ACTUALLY MEANS PEOPLE
FEEL FEEL OKAY ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK WE CERTAINLY DO SO LET ME
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION- LET ME BRING
IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT I THINK THAT WE
ARE- GOING TO SEPARATE THE VOTE
ARE AT THE REQUEST OF A MEMBER
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR I AM PREPARED TO TAKE
A MOTION AND MY COLLEAGUES WILL
CORRECT ME IF I HAVE IT WRONG ON
ITEM A- ALLEN BARCELONA BEAT
RICHARD BRAZIL AND SEE KELLY
GORDON I IS THAT CORRECT. FROM
THE.
I'M OKAY I STAND CORRECTED I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOTION ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR ARE ITEM ARE A ALLEN
BARCELONA IF I COULD HAVE A
MOTION ON ITEM A- SENATOR
LAYERED THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOUR ALLEN BARCELONA.
GROOVE KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
LAYERED- LAYERED I BATES HI
BATES AYE ATKINS HI ATKINS FORTY
ZERO FORTY ZERO THAT WILL MOVE
ON TO THE SENATE FLOR FOR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU- AND I
WILL SEE IF THIS IS CORRECT I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOTION ON
ITEM BEAT RICHARD BRAZIL ITEM C.
KELLY GORDON ITEMS D. T. THAT
NAY AT TWO. SENATOR LAYERED.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES BATES AYE ATKINS AYE
THAT'S INSIDE FORTY ZERO. OKAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL FOR YOUR-
CONFIRMATIONS ARE BEING
FORWARDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
AGAIN WITH OUR THANKS FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND ADDITIONALLY- FOR
WORKING WITH US AND BE AND SO
THOUGHTFUL- IN THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THANK YOU. LET ME ASK IF
WE NEED TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK. I ONLY LOOK AT WHAT WE
CAN GO AHEAD. OKAY THE MOTION
WAS MADE BY SENATOR LAYER ON ON
THE SECOND MOTION WHICH WAS B.
C. AND D. THANK YOU OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD THEN AND PROCEED
TO. OUR NEXT OUR APPOINTMENT- ON
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND THAT
WOULD BE OF DR JAMES HELLO SIR
AS MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. A DOCTOR LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE AND FOR YOUR BEING WITH
US TODAY I WOULD INVITE YOU TO
RECOGNIZE ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE MAKE OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS OF THEIR OWN. SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU SENATOR.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS JIM HEALTH AND I'M AN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST PRACTICING IN
SANTA CLARA. I HAVE BEEN
LICENSED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
FOR ALMOST THIRTY TWO YEARS. I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM SAN JOSE AND
I'VE BEEN A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
MY ENTIRE LIFE. IN THE FALL OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE I WAS PASSED
BY A COLLEAGUE TO HELP TRAIN
RAPID RESPONSE TEAMS AT THE
HOSPITAL WHERE I PRACTICE. RAPID
RESPONSE TEAMS ARE COMPRISED OF
CLINICIANS WHO BRING CRITICAL
CARE EXPERTISE TO THE BEDSIDE OF
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS. WHOSE
CONDITION IS WORSENING. WITH THE
HOPE OF REDUCING HOSPITAL
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY. THAT
EXPERIENCE SPARKED MY PASSION
FOR PATIENT SAFETY WHICH IS KIND
OF MY CAREER SINCE THEN. THE
FOLLOWING YEAR I WAS APPOINTED
TO A HOSPITAL QUALITY PATIENT
SAFETY LEADERSHIP ROLE WHICH I
HELD FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS.
SOON THEREAFTER I WAS ASKED TO
LEAVE POSITION PEER REVIEW. AT
THE HOSPITAL WHERE I PRACTICE
AND MORE RECENTLY I HAVE LED UP
TO REVIEW FOR KAISER PERMANENTE
PHYSICIANS AND ALL THROUGHOUT-
THE CALIFORNIA. HE SHOULD SAFETY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. I BELIEVE THIS
POSITION POSITIONS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO OBJECTIVELY
EVALUATE THE CARE WHO PROVIDE.
END WITH THE ADVICE OF EXPERTS
TAKE PROMPT ACTION TO ADDRESS
IMPROVEMENT OPPORTUNITIES. IF
CONFIRMED I WILL WORK TIRELESSLY
TO ADVANCE PATIENT SAFETY. IN
ADVOCATE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON THE BOARDS LICENSEES
TO PRACTICE MEDICINE. IN A
PROFESSIONAL HIGH QUALITY AND
SAFE MANNER. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FIRST TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN APPOINTMENTS TO
THIS POSITION. FINALLY I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY FAMILY FOR THEIR
LOVE AND SUPPORT- I WOULD FORTY
ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR LET
ME GO AHEAD AND ASK US SENATE
EARLIER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
START THIS ROUND THANK YOU ARM.
DR WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE- OKAY
I JUST HAVE TWO QUESTIONS IN THE
FIRST ONE IS THE EASIER ONE- ARE
WITCHES YOU JUST MENTIONED YOUR
EXPERIENCE ON THE KAISER-
ADVISORY COMMITTEES OF THE PEER
REVIEW. HOW DID THAT WORK DOING
pDOING THE PEER REVIEW INFORM YOU
FOR HAVING TO DO A SIMILAR TASK
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD. WELL I
THINK MY EXPERIENCE REALLY HELPS
ME EVALUATE- MATTERS THAT COME
BEFORE THE BOARD I THINK THAT-
REVIEW HAS A VERY IMPORTANT
FUNCTION NOT JUST PROVIDE
FEEDBACK AND EDUCATION OF
PHYSICIANS. BUT ALSO TO IDENTIFY
AREAS CONSENT REQUIRED FOR THE
REMEDIATION. I FEEL THAT- THAT
MY WORK AS A PEER REVIEW LEADER
DOES HELP ME INFORM MY- OF MY
WORK ON THE BOARD FOR THE PLAN
THAT THAT- EXPERIENCE- AS A
MEMBER OF THE- THANK YOU AND
THEN LET ME GET TO THE MORE
DIFFICULT QUESTION ANALYSIS TO.
SOME OF OUR LAST HEARINGS ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD FOR PEOPLE AND
PHYSICIANS SEATS WERE. RATHER
TUMULTUOUS. OF THAT DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE THAT. CONCERN ARISING ON
NOW AND YOUR APPOINTMENT BUT IT
IS REALLY ABOUT. HOW ARE YOU
MAKE SURE. DID YOU REALLY LOOK
AT SOME OF THE CASES THAT COME
IN FRONT OF YOU- AND TAKE A
SERIOUS AND FORCEFUL RESPONSE TO
OUR- ALLEGATIONS IN TERMS OF THE
REVIEW AND GENUINEACTION AND
THERE THERE HAS BEEN. NEWS
COVERAGE LOTS OF PUSHBACK FROM
CONSTITUENCY GROUPS THAT THAT
HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING AT THE
MEDICAL BOARD HOW WOULD YOU ARE-
GIVE US COMFORT THAT. THAT YOUR
GOING TO BE SOMEBODY THAT REALLY
LOOKS AT THOSE THINGS AND IS NOT
AFRAID TO TAKE TOUGH STANCE ON
CASES THAT REALLY WEREN'T. THANK
YOU SENATOR- I TAKE MY ROLE AS A
MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL WORK VERY
SERIOUSLY- I'VE BEEN A PATIENT
SAFETY LEADER FOR. THE LAST
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN YEARS AND-
PATIENT SAFETY IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME- I BELIEVE THAT AS
ACCEPTANCE OF RESPONSIBILITY TO-
OBJECTIVELY EVALUATE THE CARE
THAT WE PROVIDE AND TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTION WHEN WE IT. A
SO I DO- FEEL STRONGLY THAT I
CAN- THE FILTERS ONCE THE LIAM
AS A ROLE MODELS WERE. PROBLEM
JUST SEPARATE SHIP THAT RESPONSE
AND- THAT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
NOT JUST AT CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS WILL BE. ARE CONCERNED
AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME.
THE PROPOSAL FOR. OF THE BOARD
BUT- I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE
AND FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH IT
BUT- I JUST WANT TO ALERT YOU TO
THAT CONCERN AS IT EXISTS IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU MADAM PROTIUM
AND NON THANK YOU DOCTOR HILLS-
FOR- STEPPING FORWARD.
VOLUNTEERING TO. SIT ON THIS
BOARD WHICH IS- AS YOU KNOW FULL
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND I KNOW
THAT IN MOST OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TO YOU
BY STAFF IN EARLIER INTERVIEWS
THAT YOU'RE ALLOWED TO ALWAYS
WITH ON THE- CONCEPT THAT YOU'RE
THERE TO ENSURE THERE'S PATIENT
SAFETY AND THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE ALL ON TOP
OF AND CERTAINLY I MEAN TOP OF
OUR PRIORITY LIST. BUT A YEAR
AGO I ASKED THE MEDICAL BOARD
APPOINTEES ABOUT THE NEED TO
CREATE A PROCESS BY WHICH PEOPLE
CONTRACT THE PROXY PROCESS OF
THEIR COMPLAINTS AND WE WERE
TOLD THE BOARD IS WORKING ON IT
THAT SOMETHING THAT COMES TO US
FREQUENTLY FROM OUR OUR
DISTRICTS ARE WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS THAT THEY FILED A
COMPLAINT AND THEY NEVER HEARD
AND THEY HAVEN'T HEARD IT SAID
RUSSELL COULD YOU UPDATE US ON
THE ACTIONS THE BOARD. HAS TAKEN
TO IMPROVE NOTIFICATION AND
FRANKLY WHETHER ARE WE CAN COUNT
ON AN ONLINE COMPLAINT TRACKING
SYSTEM THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS OF
STRONGLY THOSE WHO MADE
COMPLAINTS- CAN CAN ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THE PROGRESS. OF THE
REVIEW OF THEIR COMPLAINT. I
THINK CENTER I TELL WE'RE NEVER
AT EIGHT RELY THAT THE BOARD IS
NOT ALWAYS DONE THE BEST
POSSIBLE JOB IN KEEPING A
CONSUMERS POSTED AT THE STATUS
OF THEIR COMPLAINTS. I KNOW WE
CAN DO BETTER IN FUTURE- TO
BOARD IS ACTIVELY DEVELOPING AN
ONLINE COMPLAINT TRACKING
SYSTEM. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT'S BEING DONE RIGHT NOW
USING INTERNAL BOARD RESOURCES
WHICH WILL MAKE THE PROCESS
QUICKER HOPEFULLY WORTH IT AND
PERHAPS LESS COSTLY- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WILL HEAR. AN
UPDATE ON THE SYSTEM AT OUR NEXT
BOARD MEETING WHICH IS NEXT
WEEK- I DON'T HAVE ON THAT DATE
AT WHICH THIS WILL BE GOING
ONLINE BUT IT'S MY HOPE THIS
WILL BE AN ONLINE. WEB WEB
SYSTEM WORK CONSUMERS CAN LOOK
UP. THE STATUS OF THEIR
COMPLAINTS AND THEN BE ABLE TO
ASK FOR EXPLORATION. AND THAT IS
VERY NEWS FOR WE'LL WILL WILL
HOPE THAT YOU AFTER THAT BOARD
MEETING HALF WEEK YOU MIGHT.
SEND A LITTLE NOTE AND SAY IF
THAT WAS ONE OF THE AGENDA ITEMS
THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY PROGRESS
THERE BECAUSE I THINK THAT WILL.
GO A LONG WAY IN ENSURING THE
ON. THE PUBLIC- OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT THE ISSUES THAT BEEN RAISED
ABOUT A MEDICAL BOARD ARE UNDER
REVIEW AND THERE ARE REAL
SERIOUS EFFORTS SIDE TO. ADDRESS
THOSE AND RESPOND TO THE
COMPLAINT SO WITHOUT I'M I'M OF.
IN PRETTY SATISFIED LOOKING OUT
TO CERTAINLY ON YOUR YOUR CORE
ISSUES AND ALL YOUR GOALS. SO
ARE YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR STEPPING UP
AND SERVING ON THIS BOARD. HE'S
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
BECAUSE COMELEC OR- THANK YOU
MANNA PRO TEM I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN DR FOR US SPENDING A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME WITH ME THE
OTHER DAY I'M AND- I THE
SUNDERLAND ASKED- A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION ABOUT.
PROCESS IN COMPLAINTS AND I WON
IT- DRILL DOWN ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE WITH YOU I THINK WHEN I
ASKED YOU THIS QUESTION LAST
TIME I WASN'T CLEAR AND SO MY
BAD ON THAT- HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
INVESTIGATIONS. THAT HAVE
HAPPENED THAT HAVE BEEN
INITIATED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD-
AND OFTEN TIMES. THE WELL I
GUESS THAT'S JUST THE QUESTION.
I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK CONFIRM
THAT WAS STAFF SENATOR- I
BELIEVE THE BOARD DOESN'T
MONITOR MEDIA STORIES AND HAS
THE HAS THE OPTION TO DO SO- IF
IT SOLD APPROPRIATE. OKAY BUT
YOU DON'T KNOW. LIKE GIFT.
THAT'S A RARE THING OR NOT OR IF
THAT'S A TOOL THAT YOU ALL. USE
MORE FREQUENTLY. I WOULD HAVE TO
CHECK WITH STEPHENSON OKAY. YOU
KNOW THE OTHER QUESTION I ASKED
WAS ABOUT- DRUGS ANNA AND THE
OVER PRESCRIBING OF. NARCOTICS
AND PAINKILLERS BECAUSE WE DO
KNOW THAT- ADDICTION AND OVER
PRESCRIPTION. IS REAL I AND YOU
ACTUALLY HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION THAT YOU SHARED WHEN
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BUT ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I'D ASKED HAD TO
DO WITH- THE MAKING SURE THAT
FOSTER CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL CARE AND ARE
NOT BEING OVER PRESCRIBED. AND
SO WE KNOW THAT THE BOARD IS
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
RELATED TO PHYSICIANS
PRESCRIBING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS TO FOSTER CHILDREN
AND SO- AND I SHARED WITH YOU
REPORTS THAT I'VE HEARD FROM MY
OWN COUNTY ABOUT YOUNG CHILDREN
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AGES
TWO AND THREE YEARS OLD ON
COCKTAILS OF- NARCOTICS AND SO
WANTED YOUR THOUGHTS AGAIN I
KNOW YOU SAID YOU WERE GOING TO
GET BACK TO ME ON THIS ON. HEY
HOW THE MEDICAL BOARD IS WORKING
WITH THE SS AND DH CS TO ENSURE
THAT FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
RECEIVING THE APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL CARE AND ARE NOT BEING
OVER PRESCRIBED AND THEN THE
SECOND PART OF THAT IS HOW DO
YOU THINK PHYSICIANS. YOU KNOW-
RIVA PROVIDERS AND THEN ALSO
PROVIDERS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
STATE AND COUNTY- AGENCIES HOW
SHOULD PHYSICIANS BE DISCIPLINED
WHO ARE OVER PRESCRIBING. I
THANK YOU SENATOR- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THE BOARD OF
THE BOARD DOES NOT PLACE A HIGH
PRIORITY ON ON ON THE DENTAL HIS
LITTLE PRESCRIBING TO HAVE TWO
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM- AND THE BOARD PLANS TO
RE ENGAGE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DH YES- TO
CONFIRM THAT OUR PROCESSES ARE
APPROPRIATE AND THEN MODIFIED
MISLEAD- I THINK THAT WAS
REGARDED IN INDIVIDUAL CASES
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US. AND I
WOULD WANT TO CASE BY CASE BASIS
WITH THE ADVICE OF EXPERTS THE
TERM OF STANDS A KARAMAT CAN OF
COURSE IF THEY'RE NOT MET THE
BOARD TO TAKE ACTION ON THAT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD BY BOARD
STAFF THAT SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE
CONCERNS- ON THE BOARD OF. BEING
UP PRESCRIBING IMPOSTER CHILDREN
ON A THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND-
OF THOSE FIVE CASES THREE WERE
INVESTIGATED AND THERE IS NO
STANDARD OF CARE- REACH I DON'T
FIVE- CASES- THERE IS NOT. OF
CHRISTIAN TO OBTAIN RECORDS. BUT
AGAIN DEEP PLANS TO RE ENGAGE
WITH THE- AND TEACH S. T. L.
PROCESS AND THIS NOT. THANK YOU
- THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I HOPE
THAT- THAT. THAT YOU ARE.
KEEPING MY ALL OF SOME OF THESE.
YOU KNOW THE FAR. YOUTH
POPULATION IS. OFTEN REALLY
OVERLOOKED- AND MAYBE THE GOAL
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN
ARE SORT OF SHUFFLED THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND END UP IN A HOME BUT
HOW THEY'RE TREATED- IS AS
IMPORTANT AS WHERE THEY END UP-
AND SO AND WE DO NOT- IN MY
COUNTY I DO KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN A NUMBER OF INSTANCES.
WHERE YOUNG CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF FIVE ARE ON AS MANY AS
FIVE- PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS-
AND IN THAT HAS ALERTED A NUMBER
OF FOLKS ABOUT HOW YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE BEING CARED FOR
WHILE THEY'RE TRYING TO BE
SHEPHERD THROUGH A PROCESS AND
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW- ADOPTED FOR
US SUCCESSFULLY FOSTERED AND
THEN FOR FOLKS WHO ARE NOT IN
THE FOSTER SYSTEM. BUT YOU KNOW
HAVE SUFFERED AN INJURY AND END
UP BEING PRESCRIBE SOMETHING AND
THEN GET ADDICTED TO IT- AND
THEN THERE'S A CYCLE OF OVER
PRESCRIPTIONS AND THEN WHEN THAT
CEASES TO CONTINUE YOU KNOW THEY
MAY FIND THEMSELVES I'M TRYING
TO PURCHASE YOU KNOW NARCOTICS
ILLEGALLY TO HELP HIM WITH THE
PAIN AND THEN WE END UP WITH THE
CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN NOW WITH
THAT NOW SO I DO ASK THAT YOU.
WORK WITH THE BOARD TO RE ENGAGE
ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE- RIGHT.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE GETTING A HANDLE ON
FROM MANY DIFFERENT SIDES. I
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BUT I DID WANT TO JUST SAY THAT
THANK YOU MA'AM PROTON. THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU A SENATOR
KAMLAGER- AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
OF FOR THE ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS AS FAR I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP ON- A COUPLE OF OUR
INITIATED QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- AND- AND TO ALSO SAY
STAFF IS TRACKING THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ASK FOR RESPONSES TO
AND WILL FOLLOW UP AS WE HAVE
DONE. ON PREVIOUS APPOINTMENTS
WITHOUT STANDING QUESTIONS-
RELATED TO THE- TRACKING THE
ONLINE TRACKING SYSTEM- I GUESS
ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD SAY
THAT CERTAINLY I AGREE WITH THE
VICE CHAIR. WILL BE SOMETHING
GREATLY NEEDED I THINK FOR THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS- TO GO EVEN
FURTHER THAN THAT- YOU KNOW
WE'VE THERE I THINK IT WAS JUST
A HEARING LAST WEEK I DON'T KNOW
MADAM VICE CHAIR ARE YOU ONE BMP
AS WELL BUT YES. THERE WAS JUST
ANOTHER HEARING AND THE SENATE
LAST WEEK R. AND OBVIOUSLY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND SOME MEMBERS WHO WORK ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE- WERE THERE TO
RESPOND AND ANSWER QUESTIONS. I
WOULD WOULD ASK IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW THE SENATOR LAYERS COMMENTS
ABOUT. THIS THERE IS BECOME THIS
LACK OF PUBLIC TRUST RELATED TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND OBVIOUSLY.
THE BOARD MEMBER SERVE- BECAUSE
THEIR DESIRE TO- PARTICIPATE IN
AND LOOK AT PUBLIC PROTECTION-
AND THAT ROLE IS IMPORTANT AS
YOU OUTLINED IN YOUR COMMENTS
BUT- I WOULD ASK- IN TERMS OF
THAT- THERE IS. NOT JUST A LACK
OF ABILITY TO TRACK OR NOT BE
COMMUNICATED BY THE BOARD WHEN A
COMPLAINT HAS BEEN FILED. BUT
BUT WHAT WE'VE HEARD IN PAST
TESTIMONYIS THAT THE VOICE OF
THE COMPLAINT TENS IS NO WE'RE
IN THIS PROCESS WHEREAS IF YOU
HAVE HEARINGS I THINK AND I KNOW
THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS THERE'S
THE PANELS AND- ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW AND THERE'S A WHOLE PROCESS.
WE'RE IS THE VOICE OF THE
COMPLAINT IT HEARD IN THE
PROCESS BECAUSE CLEARLY THERE'S
DUE PROCESS AND A FOOT IF A
DOCTOR HAS- A COMPLAINT AND HAS
TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS. THE
DOCTORS VOICES THERE ARE
SOMETIMES REPRESENTED BY MEDICAL
EXPERTS FOR THE DOCTOR THE BOARD
HAS MEDICAL EXPERTS THAT REVIEW.
CASES WHERE IS THE VOICE OF THE
COMPLAINT IT IN THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU SENATOR- THE
COMPLAINANT CERTAINLY IS
INTERVIEWED BY THE COMMUNITY BY
THE CENTRAL COMPLETE UNIT OF BY
THE HEALTH ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT. AND THEIR
STATEMENTS ARE ARE CERTAINLY A
VERY IMPORTANT WHEN DECIDING.
WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE IN- THE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS OR THE
DUMPING OF ACCUSATION- IT'S ALSO
POSSIBLE FOR THE PLAINTIFFS TO
BE ASKED TO TESTIFY. ACT
INDUSTRY HEARING BEFORE AN ALJ-
SO THE COMPLAINANT IS INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS TO THE EXTENT. TO
YOUR TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE DOES A
COMPLAINT AND SHE OUR COMPLAINT
IS GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AT OUR- A HEARING BEFORE
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE. I
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE CALLED AS A
WITNESS THEY CAN DIAZ TESTIFIED
THOSE HEARINGS YES. IS THERE A
PROCESS WHEREBY IF THE COMPLAINT
IT WANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS BECAUSE THE COMMENTS
I'VE HEARD TO DATE ARE THAT THEY
ABSOLUTELY NO NOTHING UNTIL
MAYBE THEY GET A LETTER AT THE
VERY END OF THE PROCESS THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE. AND
MAYBE THIS IS NOT IS IT MAYBE
THIS THAT IS NOT THE SITUATION
BUT FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD THERE
IS NO POINT OR PROCESS OTHER
THAN THE INITIAL COMPLAINT.
UNLESS CONTACTED BY INVESTIGATOR
FOR FURTHER QUESTIONS WHERE THEY
HAVE ANY. PARTICIPANT TORY ROLE
IN A THE EDUCATE AT YOU THE
RESOLUTION OF THEIR COMPLAINTS
SO YOU IS IT. WOULD MAYBE THAT
IS A QUESTION FOR THE BOARD HOW
OFTEN DOES THE COMPLAINT AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROCESS. AFTER INITIAL-
THE INITIAL COMPLAINT N. AND THE
INVESTIGATOR IS THERE ANY POINT
IN THE PROCESS WHERE THE
COMPLAINT IT HAS THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE COMPLAINANTS
DISSIPATION IS DEFINED IN THE
LAW AND THAT- FOR EXAMPLE- HE
INSTEAD OF THE PRESCRIPTION TO
PRICKLY IS TO. IS TO ACT AS A
WITNESS DURING HEARING IF THE IF
REQUESTED BY THE- THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE OR- OR OTHERS.
SO IT'S THE IT'S THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT DETERMINES
WHETHER THE COMPLAINT IT HAS A
ROLE IN ANY HEARING. I BELIEVE
SO YES OKAY IN- I NOTICED AND-
THE BACKUP MATERIALS AT
SOMEWHERE IT MENTIONS THAT THERE
ARE MULTIPLE PANELS- AND YOU'RE
ON ONE OF THOSE PANELS THAT
LOOKS AT CASES DO DO THE PANELS
FOLLOW THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES MORE SPECIFICALLY- ON
THE PROBATION PERIOD YOU'RE ON.
YOUR ON A PANEL I REMEMBER OF
HIM WILL BE A CENTER. OKAY SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT RIVER THAT
THE GUIDELINES OUR GUIDELINES
AND THEY'RE NOT FINDING- AND THE
GUIDELINES THEMSELVES STATE THAT
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF REASONS
WHY- THE MAY OR MAY NOT BE
SALAS- FOR EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE-
EVIDENTIARY PROBLEMS- THAT THE
GUIDELINES STATE THAT THE-
PHYSICIAN IS WILLING TO ACCEPT
REHABILITATION. IN THIS PART OF
THE PROCESS THAT WE MAY BE A
REASON TO BUY TICKETS AT ONCE-
THERE ARE THERE ARE SOME PLANS
THAT SITUATIONS WHERE- AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE. THAT
HER ATTORNEY GENERAL FEELS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
MEET THE CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE STANDARD. YEAH AND SO
THAT- WHEN WE ARE NEGOTIATING A
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT- WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO PROVE THE
ALLEGATION AND HEARING AND THE
SETTLEMENT ALLOWS US TO IMPOSE
SOME DISCIPLINE. THAT WE MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE A POSTER
HERE. OKAY THANK YOU- THE ARM SO
I DID I DID NOTICE THAT PANEL
THERE ARE TWO PANELS ARE THERE
MORE THAN TWO PANELS IS IT JUST
THEIR TWO PANELS TWO PANELS AND
FROM WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE IN THE
BACK OF MATERIALS- PANEL A- HAS
YOUR OWN PANEL B. PANEL A HAS
MORE PUBLIC MEMBERS PANEL B. HAS
ARE MORE PHYSICIAN MEMBERS- I'D
BE INTERESTED TO KNOW HOW OFTEN
IN THOSE PANELS. GIVEN THE
DIFFERENT MAKE UP OF THE PUBLIC
MAKE UP- MAJORITY ON ONE PANEL
AND THE MEDICAL PHYSICIAN MAKE
UP ON THE OTHER PANEL. THE HOW
OFTEN OR HOW MANY CASES ARE
ACTUALLY TAKEN OUT BY THE
PANEL'S VERSES JUST BASICALLY.
BOB IF YOU WILL APPROVED BASED
ON THE- I GUESS IT IS THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
RECOMMENDATION WHETHER YOU SORT
OF JUST CONCUR WITH THAT AND YOU
DON'T CONSIDER THE CASES ARE YOU
ARE YOU DECIDE YOU WANT TO HEAR
THEM ANYWAY IS THAT HOW IT WORKS
. SO I READ EVERY CASE THAT I
THAT I RECEIVED- AND- I CAN ONLY
SPEAK TO MY EXPERIENCE ON
CHANNEL B. I- I DON'T HAVE ANY
INVOLVED WITH PANEL EIGHT I DO.
FEEL THAT I REALLY CASES VERY
CAREFULLY I CONSIDER THIS BUT
OUR GUIDELINES FOR REACHING A
DECISION AND CERTAINLY WANT TO
CASES HELP FOR DISCUSSION I FEEL
WHAT ARE OUR PANEL. IT HAS A
VERY ACTIVE AND- HISTORY
DISCUSSION AND- I THINK THAT OUR
OUR OUTCOMES ARE. DECIDED
APPROPRIATELY. I THANK YOU- I
MIGHT BE INTERESTED TO LOOK AT
THAT DATA BUT THAT MIGHT BE MORE
IN THE VENUE OF THE BNP
COMMITTEE SO ON I WILL. I WILL
LEAVE IT IN THEIR JURISDICTION-
I THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR YOUR- FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES I DO
REALLY APPRECIATE IT- OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS IF NOT I
WILL. THANK YOU I WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY BE WISHING TO
SPEAK ON- THE APPOINTMENT AND I
WILL START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. TO SEE IF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE SHOWN
UP TO TESTIFY. I SEE NO ONE
APPROACHING THE DIETS SO LET ME
WELCOME BACK OUR MODERATOR AND
ASK IF HE WILL TEE UP. THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN THE ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LET ME GO
AHEAD AND ASK STAFF TO PUT UP
THE NUMBER RIGHT PLEASE FORGIVE
ME THE TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR THE-
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THAT ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO AND OUR MODERATOR WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD FOR
ANYONE WHO'S PREPARED TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE WE WILL I
WILL JUST LOOK QUICKLY AND SEE
THAT THERE'S STILL NO ONE HERE
AS WE MOVE TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SO MISTER
MODERATOR LET ME COME BACK TO
YOU AND ASK YOU TO T. OF THOSE
WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THAT IS ONE AND THEN THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN A FEW RIGHT WELL AND
- A LITTLE WHILE- HAVE BEEN
GIVEN EVERYONE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. FORWARD A MOTION.
SOME OF THEM ARE MADAM VICE
CHAIR- I WILL RECOGNIZE YOU TO
MAKE THE MOTION- MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
KAMLAGER I'M LONGER I LAYERED
AYE LAYERED AYE BATES BATES AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS SORRY FOUR TO
ZERO DR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME YOU WILL BE FORWARDED
TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION AND DOC- OUR STAFF
WILL FOLLOW UP ON COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS TO THE BOARD- PENDING
THIS MOVING TO THE FLOOR SO
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SERVICE
THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT REST OF
YOUR DAY. YOU AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK- RECESS NOW- AND BE BACK
PROBABLY IN FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND CALL THE-
MEETING BACK TO ORDER. WE HAVE
ONE MORE- ORDER OF BUSINESS AND
THAT WOULD BE- UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
AND THAT WOULD BE ITEM F.
CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS FOR THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. SO LET
ME- WELCOME YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE PATIENCE WE
SO MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. AND ASK
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO-
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE. THANK ANYONE
MAKE OPENING INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS AND AFTER YOU DO THAT
WE WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO ASK YOU
QUESTIONS AND MAKE COMMENTS
WELCOME. WHAT THE WHAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON A VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE MADAM CHAIR MADAM
VICE CHAIR- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT IS TRULY AN HONOR
A PRIVILEGE TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
THIS CONFIRMATION. I'D LIKE TO
THANK A FEW PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
CRITICAL TO MY ABILITY TO SERVE
IN THIS POSITION. CONFORM I LIKE
TO THANK MY FAMILY MY WIFE AND I
AND OUR TWO SONS CORNELIA SO
COLD. GIVEN THE DEMANDS THAT WE
ALL MANAGE EVERYDAY IT IS
BECAUSE OF THEIR LOVE AND
SUPPORT AND TO ALL PATIENTS THAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO ALL THE JOB
REQUIRES. I YOUR TODAY THANK. I
WOULD LIKE TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ENTRUSTING ME WITH A RESPONSE.
TO THIS NEW CAR AND IN THE NEW
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK CREATED BY
ASSEMBLY BILLS. TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND ONE ELEVEN. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK AND RECOGNIZE- PC
PRESIDENT FORMER UC PRESIDENT
MARIBEL BASHER. HER LEADERSHIP
AND GUIDANCE WAS INVALUABLE- AS
I NAVIGATED INITIALLY STANDING
UP THE WILDFIRES EACH DIVISION
AT THE P. C. AND THEN
TRANSITIONING IT OVER INTO THE
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SECRETARY CROWFOOT AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY APRIL WELCOME
ME AND THE ENTIRE OFFICE WITH
OPEN ARMS INTO THE RESOURCES
AGENCY FAMILY. AND I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO THANK YOU THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PASSING
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED IN IN
INNOVATIVE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
TO ADDRESS INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
REST. ARE YOUR VISION IS
ENABLING US TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE HOW UTILITIES UNDERSTAND
OUR WILDFIRE RISKS. AND
PRIORITIZE THEIR EFFORTS TO
REDUCE THAT RISK IN PURSUIT OF
EVENTUALLY ELIMINATING UTILITY
CAUSE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
OUR DEPARTMENT WAS BORN OUT OF
TRAGEDY WITH ARE YOU WITH
UTILITY COST BUYERS RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVER A HUNDRED DEATHS. TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF LOST HOMES AND
BUSINESSES AND MORE THAN A
MILLION AND A HALF ACRES BURNED
IN JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS.
UTILITIES MUST FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE HOW THEY ADDRESS WILDFIRE
RISK INHERENT IN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'VE SPENT THE
LAST TEN YEARS OF MY CAREER
WORKING AT THE COUNTY AND THE
STATE LEVEL. ON SOME OF THE
STATE'S TOUGH FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
CHALLENGES WITHIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. MY PASSION IS PUBLIC
SERVICE AND MAKING CALIFORNIA
SAFER FOR EVERYONE. I AM DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I
WHICH ALLOWS ME TO FOCUS MY
ENERGY ON A VERY SPECIFIC AND
CRITICAL ISSUE UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. AND PLACE
MORE PART IN HELPING MAKE
CALIFORNIA SAFER FOR OUR
RESIDENTS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS AND OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK IF IT'S OKAY MADAM
VICE CHAIR I'LL START WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM BROWN CHAIRMAN
PRO TEM AND- THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JACOBS FOR STEPPING FORWARD AND
NOW I'M GETTING THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENT
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT. I DID
READ THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE STATE
AUDIT REPORT ON YOUR OFFICE AS
WELL AS THE RESPONSES FROM THE
AUDITOR TO YOUR REBUTTALS AND IT
SEEMS THERE'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. BETWEEN
NOT FROM ALL THE I. S. AND
CERTAINLY THE AUDITOR SO THAT'D
BE GOOD TO GET YOUR ON YOUR
THOUGHTS ON ON SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES IN PARTICULAR THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
VERY ON I ENGAGE IN IN DEPTH AS
A MATTER OF FACT HOLDING
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ACTUALLY PERFORMING THE WORK TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRE. THE WILDFIRE
RISK- CERTAINLY IN THE PRESENT
AND GOING FORWARD SO JUST LIKE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT THINGS
LIKE IT WAS A LITTLE BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN YOU AN AUDITOR ON
WHETHER. THOSE THE- HE YEARS
SORT. PROCESS AND HOLDING ON
THE- UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE SEEMS
TO BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
APPROACH PERHAPS BUT BUT YOU
COULD GET THE LIGHT NOW SIGN ON
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS BECAUSE
IT'S AN EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. COMPONENTS CERTAINLY
GOING FORWARD AND FOR YOUR ROLE
AND FOR THE ROLE OF ALL WE AYE
OUT. WELL THANK YOU SENATOR-
FIRST AND FOREMOST WHAT I'D SAY
THAT YOU KNOW WE WELCOME THE
INPUT OF THE AUDITOR AND ALL THE
INPUT WITH HAS A NEW DEPARTMENT
WE'RE CONTINUALLY LEARNING. AND
ITERATING ON OUR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE STATUTORY FRAMEWORK THAT
WAS CREATED. TO OVERSEE UTILITY
WILDFIRE SAFETY US SPECIFICALLY
IT REGARDING THIS IS THE SORT OF
A FICTION- THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATION IS. VERY
PRESCRIBED IN THE STATUTE THERE
ARE SEVEN SPECIFIC CONDITIONS
THAT HAVE TO BE MET- AN ARC OUR
RESEARCH DEPARTMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING.
WHETHER THE UTILITIES NEEDS
THOSE SEVEN SPECIFIC STATUTORY-
CONDITIONS TO RECEIVE A SAFETY
CERTIFICATION AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LEFT STATUTES IS THAT IT
IS THE PURPOSE OF THE SIX
CERTIFICATION IS TO ENCOURAGE.
INVESTMENTS IN THE IN THE FUTURE
IN SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS AND SEVEN
SPECIFIC CONDITIONS THAT ARE
LISTED- THAT MUST BE MET
TOGETHER SAFETY CERTIFICATION
ARE FOCUSED ON THOSE BOARDS-
LOOKING SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS- WE
HAVE WE CERTAINLY AGREE WITH.
UTILITIES MUST BE. ALL OF FOR
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THEIR WILD
FIRE SAFETY- COMMITMENTS THAT
THEY MAKE IN THEIR OFFERING. AND
HAVE AN ENTIRE DIFFERENCE
DIVISION DOES THAT IT IS
SEPARATE FROM THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. SO ARE
COMPLIANCE DIVISION IS. FOCUSED
ON DOING FIELD EFFECT AND SHE
THAT THE. A MAN. WITH THE
COMMITMENTS THEY MADE IN THE
WILDFIRE MANY PLANS THAT ARE
ALSO. AND WE'VE DONE X. IN. AND
MOVED OF THE ACTIONS THE BILL TO
DATE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY. AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLANS AND WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING A TWENTY TWO PLANTS.
THANK YOU I GUESS WE'RE NOT
GETTING TO THE HEART OF MY
QUESTION IS WHETHER YOU INTEND
TO IMPLEMENT THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN THIS
PARTICULAR. IF YOU BECAUSE THEY
DID MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AND-
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE SOME THINGS I
GUESS YOU HAD QUESTIONS ABOUT.
IN MAY BE EXPLAINING A LITTLE
MORE ABOUT WHETHER YOU'RE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THEM OR THEIR SOME
OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HE
BELIEVED A LITTLE BEYOND THE
REACH OF THE MOMENT TIME AND I
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE I SERVED
ON THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. FOR MANY YEARS AND
WE OFTEN HAVE- OF. AN AUDIT DONE
AND YOU KNOW CRITIQUE BY THE
GRAND JURY IS A MATTER OF FACT
THAT SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
PROCESS THESE IN WE WOULD HAVE
TO RESPOND WHEN WE WERE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THEM OR WHAT. F. MORE
WHAT I'M- GOING AFTER HERE. DO
YOU BELIEVE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE AUDITOR
ARE IMPLEMENTABLE. ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THAT AT THE PRESENT
TIME. THEY'RE A LITTLE BEYOND
THE REACH. OR NOT ACCORDING TO
THE REGULATIONS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR SO IF THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS TWO OF
THEM WERE TO OUR OFFICE AND ALSO
BECAUSE THE ONE THAT WAS
REGARDING SAFETY CERTIFICATION
WAS A RECOMMEND A NATION.
ACTUALLY TO THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE IT WOULD REQUIRE A
CHANGE IN THE LEGISLATION WHAT
THEY RECOMMENDED WAS ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL CONDITION WITHIN THE
SAFETY CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS- ULTIMATELY. DEFER
TO THE LEGISLATURE. WE WILL BE
WILL WOULD IMPLEMENT WHATEVER
THE LATEST LEGISLATURE CHOOSES.
TO ACT- AND THE ADMINISTRATION-
REGARDING THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATION IN TERMS OF THE TO
OUR AUDIT- RECOMMENDATIONS TO
OUR DEPARTMENT THERE WERE TWO
ONE WAS FOR US TO- DETERMINE THE
PRIEST PRESCRIBED. LEVEL OF
SEVERITY ON A SPECIFIC TYPE OF
ISSUE THAT WE WOULD FIND IN THE
PLANS. ONE WAS FOR US. FURTHER
INCORPORATE SOME OUTSIDE OF
FINDINGS BY OTHER AGENCIES INTO
THE WILD FOR MITIGATION PLAN
CONTENT THE UTILITIES WITH
SUBMITS ALL SPEAK TO THE FIRST
ONE FIRST IN TERMS OF THE RICH
PRIVATIZATION THEY WANTED US TO
CONFIRM AND DESIGNATE RHYS
PRIVATIZATION OF THE LEVEL OF
SEVERITY OF WHAT WHAT WE CALL
CRITICAL ISSUE- WE DID DISAGREE
WITH SOMEONE NOT BE. ROOF FOR.
THERE IN PARTICULAR ISSUE FOR
ANYTHING THAT WE EVALUATE IN THE
PLANS WHEN THE PLANS ARE
REVIEWED BY AN EXTENSIVE TEAM OF
EXPERTS ENGINEERS SCIENTISTS
FIREFIGHTERS AND UTILITY POLICY
EXPERTS AND THEIR- EXTREMELY
TECHNICAL AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF FACTORS THAT WOULD GO INTO
THAT OF THAT COALITION SO WE
TAKE OUR EACH PLAN AND DO AN
EVALUATION OF THAT AND THEN-
THIS THE EXPERTS IN JUDGMENT ON
THE LEVEL OF SEVERITY OF
WHATEVER PARTICULAR ISSUE THEY
FIND- WE WOULD THEN. L. U. H. I
INCORPORATE RISK PRIORITIZATION
EXTENSIVELY THROUGH OUR
EVALUATION OF THE PLANS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS TODAY AND HAS
EXISTED FOR IT SINCE TWENTY
TWENTY IN TERMS OF THE SECOND
EVALUATION OUR SECOND RECORD. IN
TERMS OF LESSONS LEARNED WE
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE PLANS A
SECTION WHERE THE UTILITIES MUST
RESPOND TO LESSONS LEARNED AND
WE CONSTANTLY- OF ALL THINGS
THOSE WHAT WE REQUIRE IN THOSE
AFTER WE ARE. IN LOOKING IN
BRING THEIR RECOMMEND. REGARD
HEALTH AND IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE GUIDELINES WORK TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION. WELL
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL'S
RESPONSES I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT I GUESS I HAVE TO SAY I'M
NOT SURE WHAT WHAT FLOOR DO YOU
HAVE TO. ON TO MAKE UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACTUALLY
PERFORMING THE WORK. YOU KNOW ON
THE STRUCTURE THAT WOULD ALLOW-
ENFORCEMENT ACTION EIGHT FINE
WHATEVER IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
CALLED OUT SPECIFICALLY OR IS
THAT WHERE YOU NEED LEGISLATION.
REDUCE WE DO HAVE THAT YEAH NOW
UP THE CLERK THAT WAS NOT HARD.
AUDIT'S FINDINGS WE DO ALL HAVE
A REPEAT ISSUE NOTICES OF DEFECT
AND NOTICES OF VIOLATION WHEN WE
FIND- SOME TYPE OF. ISSUE WHEN
WE'RE DOING INVESTIGATIVE AND OR
AUDITS- IT WE'VE ACTUALLY
ALREADY ISSUED MULTIPLE NOTICES
OF DEFECT IN VIOLATION AND HAVE
FOUND OVER FIVE HUNDRED DEFECTS
. CORRECT. YOU TOO CORRECT THOSE
ISSUE. IN TERMS OF THE CIVIC
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY DIRECTED THEM TO
CORRECT IT- AND WE ARE
CONSTANTLY DOING THAT WE ALSO
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
AUTHORITY TO BASED ON OUR
ASSESSMENT MAKE A RECOMMENDATION
OVER TO THE COMMISSION. FOR PUT
PEDAL TEAM ACTION ARTIST DOES
NOT SPECIFICALLY HAVE AND ALL
THE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. I
THINK ONE LAST QUESTION GOES TO
WHAT YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
RESPONSES REGARDING STATUTORY
CHANGES YOU FEEL ARE NECESSARY
TO FOR YOU TO CARRY OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE.
LEGISLATIVE IS THAT MIGHT BE
REQUIRED BUT ANY SPECIFIC THAT
YOU CAN SHARE WITH OFF HOURS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN GET BACK
. ON OF YOU LET- FOR THAT THIS
WHOLE. A NEW ONE. RISK THAT THE
- AGENCY HOUSE SO ON SOMETHING
YOU'RE PREPARING TO SHARE OF
WITH US GOING FORWARD IN TERMS
OF LEGISLATIVE CHANGES NEEDED TO
GO TO I GIVE THOUGHT TO GIVE YOU
THE REACH THAT YOU NEED TO
RESPOND TO SOME ABOUT. THE
ISSUES. THE AUDIT. YES SO THE-
IMPLEMENTING THE TEN TEN FIFTY
FOUR NEW REGULATORY FAVORS A
VERY INNOVATIVE- IT'S BEEN TWO
AND A HALF YEARS NOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING IT FIRST IS A
LOT OF OUR STREETS DIVISION AND
NOW IS THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY WE ARE
ACTUALLY THIS YEAR ONLY JUST NOW
COMPLETING THE FIRST FULL CYCLE
BASED ON THIS NEW INNOVATIVE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. SO WE'RE
VERY FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTING
IMPLEMENTING THAT STATUE IN
COMPLETING THAT FIRST THAT FIRST
FULL CYCLE I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO GIVE IT TIME TO SEE IT SEE
THE SUCCESS OF THE CURRENT
INVICTA OSCAR THAT IS IN PLACE
TODAY- CERTAINLY IF WE IDENTIFY
ANY OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE
WORKING THROUGH THE NORMAL CHAIN
CHANNELS AND ADMINISTRATION TO
MAKE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. WELL
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ANSWERS IN
RESPONSE TO QUESTIONS ARE YOU
GOT A BIG JOB IN FRONT OF YOU SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FROM ALL THE
WORK YOU'RE GOING TO DO AND ALL
THE WORK YOU'VE ALREADY HAVE
DONE THANK. PRECIADO THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR- SENATOR
KAMLAGER. THANK YOU MADAM FOR
TEMAN I DON'T I ONLY HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- WANTED TO
JUST GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON- IF
YOU THINK UTILITIES ARE MAKING
SUFFICIENT PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING- THE MANY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE ASKED
FOR. THEY'RE MAKING PROGRESS I
SUFFICIENT AS IT IS AND MAY BE
PUSHING TOO FAR WE NEED TO MOVE
THEY NEED TO MOVE FASTER- AND BE
SMARTER AND HOW THEY DO IT- THE
REALITY IS THE RISK IS
CONTINUING TO BUILD WITHIN OUR
THE LANDSCAPE AND WITHIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE THERE ARE
MANY ACTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO
KEEP MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING FULLY AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY WATCHING VERY
CAREFULLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DO THAT. THEY HAVE MADE PROGRESS
THOUGH IF YOU GO BACK THREE
YEARS AGO- MOST OF THE UTILITIES
DIDN'T HAVE AN AWAY TO FULLY
ASSESS WHERE THEIR RISK WHAT. WE
CALL THE WILDFIRE RISK MODELS-
THE NOW THEY DO SO THEY'VE OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST THREE
YEARS TO THE HOUSE THE SERIOUSLY
SINCE WE'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE- A
BIG BUILD OUT MORE
SOPHISTICATED- CAPABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE RISK IS.
AND THEY'D BE GONE THEY'VE NOT
FULLY IMPLEMENTED BUT THEY'VE
BEGUN TO CHANGE HOW THEY DO
THEIR JOBS HOW THEY DO THEIR
BUSINESS HOW THEY BUILD HOW THEY
OPERATE AND HOW THEY MAINTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT RISK. IT WILL TAKE
A LOT TO GET IT ALL DONE THEY
NEED MORE TIME AND THEY NEED
MORE RESOURCES TO DO IT- BUT
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS BUT
THEY NEED TO MOVE FASTER IN THE
SUMMER. AND YOU'RE UNION IF- WE
S. REVIEW OR SIR. ONE OR VARIOUS
TRANSMISSION LINES AND THEN
SOMETHING GOES SIDEWAYS. DOES
NOT ALLEVIATE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE UTILITY. JUST TO CLARIFY
WE DO NOT CERTIFY TRANSMISSIONS
ARE SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THERE
IS ALSO THE- FEDERAL REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OF THOSE AND THE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN US AND THE
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION STILL.
OWNS THE RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
AUTHORITY TO SET THE
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS- THAT
THESE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS
BUILT ON- BUT I TO YOUR POINT
THOUGH IN TERMS OF WHEN WE GO
OUT THERE AND DO INVESTIGATIONS
WHICH ARE FOCUSED ON ARE THEY
IMPLEMENTING THE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY ARTICULATED AND WERE
APPROVED IN ANY PLAN THAT WE
APPROVED- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THAT DOES NOT IN ANY WAY.
TAKE AWAY OR REDUCE THEIR
LIABILITY- TO OPERATE THE GRID
SAFELY- ALTERNATELY- ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAUSES AN
IGNITION WOULD STILL BEAT UP
PROCESS THROUGH THE COMMISSION'S
WORK- WHILE THE PUBLIC SAFETY OR
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION'S
WILDFIRE INVESTIGATION PROCESS
IN TERMS OF THE- REASONABLENESS
OR NEGLIGENCE THAT THEY HAD. FOR
HOW THAT TECHNICIAN HAPPENS.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SENATORS LAYERED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
MEETING WITH ME I REALLY.
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION AND
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
GOTTEN A LOT OF THE THINGS I
WANT WANTED TO GET AT BUT I
STILL HAVE SORT OF THE QUESTION
THAT IS CENTRAL TO OUR
CONVERSATION WHICH IS. YOU HAVE
THE PRESCRIBED MEASURES IN THE
LAW. AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
SAFETY PLANS AND TRYING TO.
JUDGE THAT THEY'RE BEING MATT.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS ACTUALLY LEADS TO WHAT
THE POLICY GOALS OR IT BECAUSE
WE ARE WE CONFIRM PEOPLE FOR
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND I JUST
HAVE. THEIR WROTE PROCESSES AND
THEY GO THROUGH THE PROCESSES
AND I THINK THAT'S THE GOOD AND
AT SOME POINT TO NAY FORGET
SOMETIMES THAT THEY'RE CONNECTED
TO ACTUAL OUTCOMES SO AND I KNOW
ALSO THAT YOU'VE CHANGED
AGENCIES I THINK YOU'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF OVER TWO YEARS
TRIPLING YOUR STAFF I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A MOVING TARGET. ARE BUT
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING AT THE PROBLEM
THAT THIS OF THESE PLANS IN THIS
AGENCIES FORM TO ADDRESS. ALL
THANK YOU SENATOR- I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU AT THE END OF THE
DAY THIS IS ABOUT DO WE CHANGE
THE OUTCOMES ARE WE IMPROVING
SAFETY OUTCOMES FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA- IT
COMES DOWN TO. ARE WE NOT HAVING
MISSIONS BASED ON UTILITY COST
INFRASTRUCTURE- ISSUES SO I TELL
HIM ALL THE TIME OUR JOB BOILS
DOWN TO. SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF SPARKS THAT TURN
INTO IGNITIONS FROM ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
ELIMINATING THE SPARKS THE TURN
INDIGNATION THAT POTENTIALLY
TURN INTO CATASTROPHIC FIRES- SO
TO ME THAT'S THE END GOAL AND WE
WHAT WE MONITOR THAT VERY
CLOSELY. SO WE MONITOR EVERY DAY
THE IGNITION RATES FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE- INTERNET UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
STANDING UP THE DEPARTMENT WOMAN
MOVED OVER FROM THE COMMISSION
IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT. IS WE
IMPLEMENTED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS TO OBVIOUSLY RUN OUR
DEPARTMENT AND WE REQUIRE THE
UTILITIES TO SUBMIT TO US-
IGNITION REPORTS. EVERY TIME
THEY HAVE A TECHNICIAN- THEY
HAVE TO TELL THEM TELL US ABOUT
IT AND WE TRACK THAT AND THE
GOAL HERE IS FOR US TO SEE A
TREND LINE DOWN IN THE NUMBER OF
IGNITIONS. AND ELIMINATION OF
IGNITIONS THAT CASH FIRES SO
THAT IS OUR IN GAME THAT WE
MONITOR REALLY CLOSELY
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE DO. HAVE
TO DRIVE THAT NUMBER GO DOWN.
THEN ME THE CHAIR OF. ASK YOU
ABOUT RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE NOT SO YOU GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND YOU
REALIZE ALL THE THINGS YOU WERE
GIVEN IN THE LEGISLATION OR THE
THINGS THAT ARE PRESCRIBED IN
THE PLANTS. DON'T GIVE YOU SOME
TOOLS THAT REALLY GET IT THIS
ARE YOU A POWER TO COME TO US
AND SAY WE REALLY NEED TINKERING
WITH THE LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
REAL TOOL THAT ALLOWS US TO
COMPLETELY GET IT THIS. AND
MAYBE THAT'S A DUMB QUESTION I
WS I HAD A MINOR ROLE IN THAT
AGENCY AND I DON'T THINK WE WERE
FOR POWER TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT CHECKING WITH
FIVE PEOPLE. BUT BUT NEVER. BUT
NEVER THE LESS I MEAN WOULD THAT
BE A GOAL THAT YOU TRY TO WORK
IT THROUGH THE CHAIN TO CALM AND
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO FIX SOMETHING THAT
THAT GIVES YOU A TOOL THAT YOU
WISH YOU HAD. I KNOW THAT I HAVE
THE FULL SUPPORT OF ON BOTH THE
AGENCY AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING OUR JOB AND
IF THAT MEANS HAVING
DISCUSSIONS- TO TALK ABOUT.
FUTURE CHANGES. THROUGH THE
PROPER PROPER CHANNELS-
ABSOLUTELY WE WOULD WE WOULD DO
THAT- EVERYONE IS ON THE SAME
PAGE THAT WHAT WE MUST TO DO. IS
TO CHANGE HOW THE UTILITIES ARE
BUILDING OPERATING AND
MAINTAINING THEIR GRADE TO AVOID
FUTURE FIRES- SO I THINK WE'RE
ON THE SAME PAGE THAT I KNOW
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE THERE-
AND YOU. I CAN CERTAINLY- TELL
YOU THAT THAT'S MY JOB IS I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE DO. I WILL
CONSIDER MYSELF SUCCESSFUL IN
THIS ROLE IN LESS WERE MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION- JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO DO THAT BUT IT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE YOU NEED THE
ENCOURAGEMENT. IS THE ARM. AND
DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY AS THE SITUATION
CHANGES I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE P.
GENIES ANNOUNCED THEY WANT TO
SPEND TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO UNDERGROUND. WHAT'S
JUST SAY THEY WERE REALLY
SUCCESSFUL AND ONE OF THAT. ARE
DOES THAT MEAN YOU WOULD HAVE TO
THAN REALLY A MENTOR TO ADDED
SAFETY PLANS BECAUSE- THE WHOLE
PROCESS IS BASED ON WHAT THE
CURRENT SITUATION IS OF POWER
LINES AND WHAT'S ABOVE GROUND TO
MEET. HOW WILL. WHAT YOU DO MOVE
WITH THE CHANGES THAT HAPPENED
IN THE INDUSTRY OR ON THE GROUND
. YEAH I THINK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION THAT'S ACTUALLY A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION I
THINK IT'S THE BEAUTY IN THE WAY
THAT THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
WAS SET UP THROUGH. THE CREATED
IT- AND I SAID I WILL CERTAINLY
WASN'T A PART OF THAT BUT I HAVE
TO SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE-
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FOR SIDE THAT
THEY HAD IN CREATING THAT
FRAMEWORK SO BECAUSE IT IS AN
ANNUAL ITERATIVE PROCESS. EVERY
YEAR WE ARE INFORMING AND
ADJUSTING AND CHANGING BASED ON
BOTH WHAT THAT HAVE LITERALLY
THE LANDSCAPE HAS CHANGED AS
WELL AS THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE
NEEDS HAVE CHANGED- ARE CHANGING
SO WE ACTUALLY A PRETTY DYNAMIC
PROCESS- TO BE ABLE TO. FEED IN
TO OUR GUIDELINES THAT WE
DEVELOP- FOR THE UTILITIES. POST
TO SUBMIT PLANS AND WHAT IS ALL
THE CONTENT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE- AS WELL AS OUR
EVALUATION PROCESS. SO THEIR
THREE YEAR PLANS BUT THEY
PROVIDE US AN UPDATE EVERY YEAR
SO THAT PROCESS IS BUILT INTO
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED HERE FOR CONTINUAL
IMPROVEMENT AND ADJUSTMENTS. K.
F. I JUST APPRECIATE OF THE
EXCHANGE AND I KNOW. NO
RESOURCES AGENCY HAS WHOLE
BUNCHES OF PLANTS AND LAST YEAR
I DID A BILL TO PUT THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FIRE GOALS
INTO A PLAN AND MAKE IT
ADAPTIVELY MANAGED OVER FIVE
YEARS HE COULD REALLY- NO THAT
THAT THOSE GOALS ARE GOALS THAT
HAVE TO BE REALIZED AND THAT YOU
COULD GET AT THEM AS- THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ON THE GROUND
CHANGE. AND SO I JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER AND
FOLLOWING THIS BECAUSE- YOU'RE
DOING INCREDIBLE WORK AND I KNOW
I HAVE A DISTRICT. THAT IS
HEAVILY PRONE TO FIRE AND- R.
AND A AND THE ONE THAT I WAS
PACKED AND READY TO GO ON A
SEXUAL LIGHTNING FIRE IN A
LIGHTNING STORM WAS NOT DUE TO
A- TO A POWER COMPANY BUT- I WAS
SECRETARY. AT THE TIME OF THE
PARADISE FIRE AND OTHER ONES
THAT WERE REALLY. I THINK HAVE
DRIVEN HOME THE NEED FOR YOUR
AGENCY AND THE REASON THAT SO
MANY POSITIONS HAVE BEEN ADDED
SO I JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT YOU DO.
VERY IMPORTANT WORK THANK YOU
FOR BEING WILLING TO SERVE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED- ARE I LOVE
A LOT OF GROUND COVERED ALREADY.
I ONLY HAVE ONE I THINK FAIRLY
SIMPLE QUESTION- IN TERMS OF-
THE THIS MOVING INTO- E. I. S.
N. RELATED TO THE APPROVAL OF
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS. PRIOR
UNDER THE C. P. U. C. THERE WAS
AN INTERVENER BOB KIND OF ROLE
HOW DO CONSUMERS ARE BEST GET
ACROSS OF THEIR INTEREST OR
CONCERNS IN THIS REVIEW PROCESS
NOW WHAT WHAT IS THAT PROCESS
AND DO YOU FEEL. GOOD ABOUT IT
BE AN ADEQUATE TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS I KNOW SOME OF THE STUFF
IS PRETTY COMPLEX IT'S WHICH IS
PROBABLY WHY THERE WAS A WHOLE
INTERVENOR. PROCESS FOR SOMEONE
TO BE PAID TO REPRESENT
INTERESTS BUT HOW DO YOU VIEW IT
IN YOUR ROLE NOW. ON THE REVIEW
OF THOSE PLANS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO WE'VE FOR THE MOST PART
HE CAN THE SAME PROCESS THAT WE
HAD OVER THE COMMISSION. AND
REPLICATED UNDER THE UNDER THE
NEW DEPARTMENT SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT WE CAN WILL
RECEIVE STAKEHOLDER COMMENT
WHETHER THAT'S GENERAL PUBLIC OR
INTERVENORS FOLKS THAT ARE- THAT
ARE TRADITIONALLY THANK YOU CAN
GAUGE ON THE COMMISSION'S
PROCEEDINGS- SO THERE'S STILL A
PROCESS FOR THEM TO DO THAT. WE
DO PUBLIC WORKSHOPS- WE ACCEPT
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ACCEPTED-
COMMENT ON BOTH THE PLANS AS
WELL AS OUR EVALUATIONS OF THE
PLANS- WE'VE ALSO REPLCATED- ON
OUR WEBSITE A PROCESS TO READ
RECEIVE ALL OF THIS SO THERE'S
AN ELECTRONIC FILING SYSTEM- SO
FOR THE MOST PART. IT'S NOT
EXACTLY A DUPLICATION OF HOW THE
PHYSICIAN HAS IT- BUT WHERE
WHERE WE COULD WE KEPT THAT SAME
STRUCTURE IN PLACE OF THE SIX
THREE RULING IMPORTANT TO US TO
CONTINUE TO GET. EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS- PARTICULARLY THE
INTERVENORS FROM THAT HAVE COME
WITH US FROM THAT THE COMMISSION
ON THAT ARE DEEPLY TECHNICAL
EXPERTS IN THIS AREA TO GET
THEIR COMMENTS BECAUSE THEY HELP
US THEY HELP OUR EVALUATION BE
RICHER AND FULLER- SO WE'VE
WE'VE CONTINUED THAT PROCESS.
AND THE STATUTE WITH AUTHORITIES
THAT CAME OVER IN THE NEW
EXPERTISE WE GOT WHEN WE BECAME
THE DEPARTMENT IT REQUIRES THAT
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS ALSO
WE ARE CERTAINLY IMPLYING THAT
TO MEET THAT REQUIREMENT- BUT-
SOMETIMES GOING EVEN ABOVE AND
BEYOND. DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
GETTING GOOD AYE GOOD COMMENTS
GOOD FEET TO FEET TO ROBUST. AS
IT. ALWAYS SEEMINGLY HAS BEEN.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE FOR YEAR
THE WE OF HER THROUGH THE-
LESIONS ON THE PLAN EVALUATIONS.
HOLY AS OUR OWN DEPARTMENT RIGHT
LAST YEAR IN THE SPRING WE ARE
STILL PART OF THE COMMISSION. US
SO THAT PROCESS CITY YEAH. YEAH
SO I WOULD SAY THAT- WE
CERTAINLY ARE STILL SEEING
ENGAGEMENT- I HAVEN'T HEARD OF
THE OF IT A SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF
AND WE MAY HAVE HAD SOME PEOPLE
CHANGE- I KNOW THE LAST PUBLIC
WORKSHOP THAT WE HAD. A WE HAD
OVER A HUNDRED PEOPLE- IT FROM
THE PUBLIC FROM STAKEHOLDERS
ENGAGED IN THAT WORKSHOP WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS A PRETTY ROBUST
SHOWING- AND SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE HAD WHEN WE WERE AT
THE COMMISSION- SO I'VE NOT SEEN
THAT DROP OFF. BUT IT IS STILL
IN THE BEGINNING STAGES OF THAT
UNDERSTOOD WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT. IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW THAT TRANSITIONS OVER
TIME AND I'M SURE WE'LL TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT IN VARIOUS
HEARINGS AND- ARE. YOU KNOW-
CHECK INS THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEES AND BUDGET WHAT HAVE
YOU. THANK YOU OF THE
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU- ON THIS
TRANSITION AND- I AGREE WITH
SENATOR LAYERED YOUR ENTHUSIASM
OBVIOUSLY. IS MUCH NEEDED AS
YOU- ENDEAVOR IN THIS NEW NEW
PROCESS IN A. NEW WAY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
LET ME GO AHEAD AND PUT THAT
NUMBER UP THERE ONE MORE TIME I
FEEL LIKE A CAR SALES PERSON
FRANKLY ON A- ON A ON A TV AD
FROM THE FIFTIES- LEASED MY- AGE
START TO SHOW. OF WE'RE GONNA
PUT THE NUMBER UP IT'S A TOLL
FREE NUMBER FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE- EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO
pWOULD LIKE TO USE THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. BUT I'M
GONNA START RIGHT HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. HI THIS IS
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN SUPPORT. OF
THERE ISN'T- ANYONE FROM THE
PUBLIC HERE APPROACHING THE
DICE. SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
AND WELCOME BACK OUR MODERATOR.
TO T. AT PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU DO
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
LINE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING MEMBERS PAUL WAS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S VISORS ON BEHALF OF
REQUIRE IN SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITHOUT THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU ARE MISTER
MODERATOR HANG OUT FOR A SEC
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO INVITE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED BUT THERE IS NO ONE FROM
THE PUBLIC HERE SO MISTER
MODERATOR LET ME ASK YOU TO TEE
UP ANYONE WHO MIGHT WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
WE LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ME PLUS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
YOU CAN USE YOUR PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
HELP TODAY MISTER MODERATOR WE
APPRECIATE IT GREATLY HAVE A
GOOD REST OF YOUR DAY- OKAY HAVE
BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
TO- THE SENATORS AND I WOULD ASK
SENATOR LAYER TO MAKE HIS MOTION
ARE WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SIR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LAYERED AYE BATES. BATES NOT
VOTING ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO IF THIS
MOVES FORWARD TO THE FULL SENATE
FOR CONFIRMATION LET ME THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR TIME TODAY AND
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU OKAY
I CLEARLY THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING
TO BE A MUCH LONGER HEARING
TODAY BUT THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S
AGENDA SO LET ME THANK ALL OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO DID
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO DO
THAT PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS- AGAIN
YOUR COMMENTS REALLY ARE. ALL
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR TESTIMONY IS
INCLUDED IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. AND WITH THAT LET ME
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
YOUR COOPERATION AND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED.